THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW WILL
COME TO ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON
RESPONDS TO THE PROBE IN
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT ALL OF US WE ARE IN
HEARING TO SOCIAL DISTANCE IN
FEET COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO OUR NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THE PUBLIC STILL HAS ACCESS TO
OUR PROCESS. OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING IS BEING HELD HERE IN
THE CAPITAL HOWEVER WE HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. AND I
KNOW REMOTE PARTICIPANTS YOU
KNOW THE YEP TO MUTE YOUR PHONE
OR COMPUTER AND THEN WHEN YOU
WANT TO BE RECOGNIZED USED TO
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE. AND
THEN- WHEN YOU RECOGNIZE THAT
POP UP WINDOW WILL ASK IF YOU'D
LIKE TO IN MUTE SELECT ON MUTE.
THEN WHEN YOU'RE FINISHED
SPEAKING OUR I. T. DEPARTMENT
WILL MEET YOU. TO ALLOW PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO HERE IN THE
SENATE CHAMBERS PLUS TO AN
ADDITIONAL HEARING ROOM AND
WE'LL BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. SO
THOSE OF YOU WHO WANT TO
TESTIFY. USING THE PHONE. THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS ON THE
SENATE BUDGET COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WILL ALSO BE ON OUR
SCREEN. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
THREE THREE SIX FOUR FOUR THREE
SEVEN THE ACCESS CODE IS EIGHT
TWO SIX EIGHT FOUR TWO EIGHT.
AND IN ORDER FOR US TO NOTE
HERE YOU CLEARLY PLEASE MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE MANNER AS WE
USUALLY DO. THERE MAY BE SOME
LACK TIMES WITH TECHNOLOGY SO
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT. NOW LET ME SEE IF WE
HAVE A QUORUM YET. WE DO NOT SO
WE'RE GOING TO START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. BECAUSE WE ARE
ALREADY- TWENTY MINUTES BEYOND
THE TIME THAT WE HAD ANNOUNCED
ONE SECOND DO WE HAPPY NO WE DO
NOT SO WE'RE GONNA START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. AND- THIS IS OUR
FINAL BUDGET COMMITTEE FOR THIS
YEAR WE HAVE SIXTEEN BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA. AND THE BILLS
PRIMARILY REFINE OR FINALIZE
ISSUES THAT WERE PART OF THE
JUNE BUDGET AGREEMENT SO YOU'LL
NOTICE THAT. THE TRAILER BILLS
THAT ARE BEFORE US REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS THAT WE HAVE
ALREADY APPROVED IN THAT JUNE
BUDGET- THEY ARE JUST THAT
REFLECT. THE STATUTORY LANGUAGE
THAT WILL NEED TO IMPLEMENT
THAT MONEY THAT WE'VE ALREADY
PROVED. AND I REALIZED THAT-
HAVING HEARINGS LIKE THIS WHERE
WE DON'T GET TO INTERACT
DIRECTLY WE ONLY CAN DO IT
THROUGH THE SCREENS WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN LA- SO
IT'S A BIT TOUGH- BUT WE CAN BE
VERY PROUD OF THE WORK THAT WE
HAVE DONE AS A COMMITTEE THIS
YEAR. WE HAVE ENACTED A
HISTORIC BUDGET THAT MAKES
CRITICAL INVESTMENTS NECESSARY
TO ENSURE A STRONGER AND MORE
EQUITABLE CALIFORNIA. AS WE
DEAL WITH ANY MERCH FROM
CHALLENGES SUCH AS THE PANDEMIC
WILDFIRES AND OTHERS THAT WE
FACE. AND LET ME JUST HIGHLIGHT
A FEW OF THE REALLY-
TRANSFORMATIVE INVESTMENTS THAT
WE HAVE AUTHORIZED IN THE
ADOPTION OF R. TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUDGET. INCLUDE
SCHOOL MEALS FOR ALL OF OUR K.
THROUGH TWELVE STUDENTS
REGARDLESS OF INCOME. UNIVERSAL
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN WHICH
WE WILL ACHIEVE FOR ALL
CHILDREN FOUR YEARS OLD UP- IT
WITHIN THREE YEARS. WE'VE
GREATLY INCREASED OUR ACCESS TO
CHILDCARE WE'VE GIVEN THE
LARGEST EXPANSION TO CALGARY ON
SWITCHES ARE FINANCIAL AID. FOR
OUR- COLLEGE STUDENTS ATTENDING
CALIFORNIA CAMPUSES. WE
REBOOTED OUR MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP WE'VE EXPANDED MEDI
CAL SO THAT ALL INCOME ELIGIBLE
CALIFORNIANS FIFTY PLUS YEARS
OF AGE MAKE IT HEALTHCARE. WE
ESTABLISH THE YOUTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INITIATIVE AND A
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONTINUUM
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM. WE
PERMANENTLY RESTORED THE 7%
HOURS THAT WERE CUT TO OUR IN
HOME HEALTH SERVICES AND THAT
WAS VERY NEEDED GIVEN HOW MANY
PEOPLE WERE OF COURSE STUCK
HOME EVEN MORE DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. WE PROVIDING TWELVE
BILLION IN NEW FUNDING FOR
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS OVER THE
NEXT TWO YEARS A SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT IN BUILDING OUT
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE. JUST
UNDER TWELVE BILLION IN
PAYMENTS TO LOW AND MODERATE
INCOME CALIFORNIANS THROUGH OUR
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS PROGRAM
AND MANY PEOPLE ARE GETTING
THOSE CHECKS NOW. AND OF COURSE
WE AUTHORIZED BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF GRANTS FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES AND TODAY WE HAVE
SOME VERY SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES
PACKAGES ON WILDFIRE DROUGHT OR
GOLDEN OUR SKEWS ME OR
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND.
CLIMATE RESILIENCY AND MORE I
WANT TO THANK STAFF FROM BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE OUR PARTNERS
IN THE ASSEMBLY OR LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND THE GOVERNOR.
FOR COMING TOGETHER AND WORKING
OUT ALL OF THE DETAILS NOT ONLY
OF TODAY'S ACTIONS BUT THE
ACTIONS OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF
MONTHS. AND WE KNOW THERE'S
STILL MORE TO ACCOMPLISH BUT
WE- WE I AM AND WE SHOULD ALL
BE VERY PROUD OF THE
ADVANCEMENTS WE'VE MADE. IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT
NOW FOR COMMITTEE TODAY WE ALL
HAVE. THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
PRESENT ALL SIXTEEN BILLS SINCE
MANY OF OUR MORE TECHNICAL
THERE'S SOME SUBSTANTIVE BILLS
YES BUT MANY OF THE MORE
TECHNICAL IN NATURE. SO WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE THEM PRESENT ALL
SIXTEEN BILLS PRIOR TO MEMBER
QUESTION AND DISCUSSION WE WILL
THEN HAVE OUR MEMBER QUESTION
AND DISCUSSION. AND THEN WE
WILL FOLLOW THAT WITH UP TO ONE
HOUR OF PUBLIC COMMENT WHICH
CAN BE ON ANY OR ALL OF THE
BILLS AND THEN AFTER THAT
COMMENT WE WILL VOTE ON THE
BILLS LET ME CALL ON. MY GOOD
VICE CHAIR SENATOR NIELSEN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. RECEIVE ADEQUATE.
FOR YOUR PACKAGE SO. I'M GONNA
LET THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THEN BEGIN ON THE PRESENTATION
OF THE BILLS AND STAFF YOU WILL
ALERT ME WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM-
SO THAT WE COULD ESTABLISH RULE
LET ME SEE IF WE DO NOW THREE.
SIX EIGHT- WE MAY HAVE IS
TWELVE CORN. I THINK WE HAVE A
QUORUM PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR KERR- READ HE NEEDS HIS
MY CONSULTANT IS TO STOP AND
SHOP. OKAY GO AHEAD MR THE
PROJECT. SENATOR SKINNER I'M
HERE SKINNER HERE NILSSON.
NILSSON HERE COPYRIGHT. CORTESE
DOLLY DOLLY HERE THE RAZA
RATHER HEAR A MAN HERE IN HERE
GROSS. GROWTH HERE COM LAGER
COME OVER HERE WHERE. WIRE HERE
MELINDA'S MELINDA'S PRESENT
MEN. MEN HERE NEWMAN NEWMAN
HERE CONTROLLABLE TROUBLED HERE
PEN PEN HERE STERN BY CAL SKI.
MY COFFEE HERE LEHRER HERE.
COPYRIGHT IS ALSO HERE COPY-
HERE. ALL RIGHT THAT
ESTABLISHES A QUORUM. BUT WE
WILL NOW BEGIN WITH THE BILLS-
FROM PARK RATHER THE
PRESENTATION BY OUR DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND I'M- THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE- MISS LYRICALLY
WILL YOU BE PRESENTING. YEAH
TERRIBLY AT GREAT GO AHEAD GOOD
EVENING OUT YOUR SKIN- MEISTER
NAILED THE NUMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ERIC LEAD WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
PRESENT AS A STATED ON SIXTEEN
BUDGET BILLS- IN THESE BILLS
REPRESENT THREE PARTY
AGREEMENTS ON SIGNIFICANT
BUDGET PROPOSALS FOR WHICH
FUNDS ARE ALLOCATED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
BUT- BUT AS YOUR SKIN ARE
MENTIONED. BUT FURTHER WORK WAS
NECESSARY TO PROGRAM THESE
DOLLARS. AN EXTRAORDINARY
AMOUNT OF WORK HAS GONE INTO
CLOSING WHAT HAS BEEN AN
EXTRAORDINARY BUDGET YEAR
STARTING WITH THE PROJECTED. A
RECORD DEFICIT AND ENDING WITH
A RECORD SURPLUS ALONG WITH
ADDITIONAL BILLIONS OF FEDERAL
CODE NINETEEN RELIEF BEING SENT
TO BOTH CALIFORNIA AND
CALIFORNIANS. AS REQUESTED I
WILL REPRESENT I WILL PRESENT
HIGHLIGHTS FROM EACH BUILT BACK
TO BACK AND THEN JOINED BY MY
COLLEAGUES. FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE WE ARE HAPPY TO. THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU WITH THAT I
WILL BEGIN WITH- AB SP ONE
SEVENTY THIS IS THE BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR THAT AMENDS THE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET ACT- THIS
BILL INCLUDES PROGRAM DETAILS
FOR APPROXIMATELY EIGHT POINT
SIX BILLION IN INVESTMENTS OVER
MULTIPLE YEARS TO DRESSING
REDUCES STATE MULTI FACETED
CLIMATE RISKS RANGING FROM
WATER RESILIENCE WILDFIRES HEAT
AND SEA LEVEL RISE AND SUPPORT
FOR NATURAL RESOURCES INCLUDING
FISH AND WILDLIFE HABITAT AND
PARKS. IT INVESTMENTS ARE IN
ADDITION TO THE APPROXIMATELY
SEVEN POINT FOUR BILLION OVER
FOUR YEARS THEY'RE ALREADY
PROGRAMMED IN INCLUDED IN THE
BUDGET FOR A TOTAL INVESTMENT
OF APPROXIMATELY SIXTEEN
BILLION. ACROSS VARIOUS TIME
INVESTMENT PRIORITIES IT'S
BASICALLY I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT
THIS BUDGET TWELVE FIRE WATER
AND CLIMATE RESILIENCE
INVESTMENTS- APRIL THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED AN EARLY
ACTION PACKAGE TOTALLING FIVE
HUNDRED THIRTY SIX MILLION- FOR
A BROAD SET OF INVESTMENTS THAT
SUPPORT A STATEWIDE STRATEGY
FOCUSED ON FOREST HEALTH AND
FIRE PREVENTION. THIS FUNDING
WILL. BUT STARTED COMING FIRE
SEASON INSPIRED DRESSING A
PIPELINE OF CRITICAL PROJECTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND
LAUNCHING SEVERAL NEW PROGRAMS-
IMPORTANT TO NOTE OVER 85% OF
THIS FUNDING HAS BEEN AWARDED.
THE SPELL- THIS BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR INCLUDES AN ADDITIONAL
NINE HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT
MILLION IN TE CURRENT YEAR. IN
ADDITIONAL WILDFIRE AND FOREST
RESILIENCE INVESTMENTS IN TOTAL
THIS REPRESENTS A ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION INVESTMENTS TO
SUPPORT- WILDFIRE AND FOREST
RESILIENCE WOULD REPRESENT THE
LARGEST INVESTMENT IN STATE.
HISTORY THESE ARE ACTIVE IN.
BUT IT ALSO INCLUDES. CHANGES
AND ESTABLISH A TWO HUNDRED
MILLION- ANNUAL CONTINUES
PREPARATION FROM THE GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION FUND. FOR
WILDFIRE AND FOREST RESILIENCE
ACTIVITIES FROM TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE ROW TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY NINE. ABOUT FIVE YEARS-
SORRY THAT'S THREE TO. SEVEN
YEARS I'M DISAPPOINTED I'M
GOING CONTINUES COMMITMENT TO
THESE TOPICS. ADDITIONALLY THE
BELL BRINGS THE TOTAL WATER IN
DROUGHT RESILIENCE PACKAGE TO
FIVE POINT TWO BILLION OVER
THREE YEARS TO PROVIDE
IMMEDIATE DROUGHT SUPPORT AND
TRUST LONG TERM WATER MILLIONS.
THIS INCLUDES THREE POINT SEVEN
BILLION OVER THREE YEARS TO
SUPPORT THE CLIMATE RESILIENCE
PACKAGE- INVESTMENTS THAT
ADDRESS THE STATE'S MULTI
FACETED I'M INTEREST INVESTING
IN BEST AVAILABLE CLIMATE
SCIENCE TO INFORM DECISIONS.
AND BUILDING COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE AND CAPACITY OR
RESOURCES ARE MOST NEEDED- IN
ADDITION AV EIGHT ONE SEVENTY
SUPPORTS CASH FLOW LOANS TO
QUALIFIED DISTRICT HOSPITALS TO
ADDRESS FINANCIAL IMPACT OF THE
KOBE NINETEEN PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY. THE BILL ALSO
PROVIDES EXPENDITURE THIRTY
THREE KOBE NINETEEN RELATED
FEDERAL GRANTS TO SUPPORT STATE
AND PERSONS FOR INSTRUCTION.
THE AMOUNT OF EIGHT HUNDRED
EIGHTY SEVEN MILLION- EXPANDING
TESTING CAPACITY DETECTION AND
CONTAINMENT AND THE AMOUNT OF
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION AND PREFER
SPONSOR HIGH RISK IN
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS IN THE
AMOUNT OF NINETEEN MILLION.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL
TEMPORARILY EXPANDS ELIGIBILITY
FOR STATE FUNDED CASH
ASSISTANCE AND OTHER SERVICES
TO AFGHAN ARRIVALS IN ELIGIBLE
FOR FEDERALLY FUNDED BENEFIT.
IT PROVIDES AN ADDITIONAL
ELEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION TO
THE STATE PROJECT
INFRASTRUCTURE FUND FOR DESIGN
AND PRE CONSTRUCTION ACTIVITIES
RELATED TO THE VISITOR CENTER A
COMPONENT OF THE STATE CAPITOL
ANNEX PROJECT AND FOR ENHANCED
SECURITY UPGRADES. BOB AS PART
OF THE ACCESS TO JUSTICE
PACKAGE THE BUDGET INCLUDES
THIRTY MILLION PURPORTS TO
COVER THE EMPLOYMENT PASTA FOR
INTERPRETERS. AND TWO THREES
LANGUAGE ACCESS AS AS WELL AS
THIRTY MILLION TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF REPORTERS AND FAMILY
AND CIVIL LAW CASES. PUTTING ON
TO A. B. ONE FIFTY FIVE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE. THIS BILL
MAKES VARIOUS CHANGES RELATED
TO PUBLIC RESOURCES INCLUDING
ESTABLISHING. THAT TWO HUNDRED
MILLION ANNUAL CONTINUES A
PERFORATION OF MENTIONED
EARLIER FROM THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND- FOR WILDFIRE
AND FOREST RESILIENCE
ESTABLISHES ANNUAL REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR PROGRAMS
RELATED TO WILDFIRE AND FOREST
RESILIENCE FUNDED IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET ACT. REMIND CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT
REQUIREMENTS FOR PROJECTS THAT
CONSERVE RESTORE PROTECTOR
ENHANCE FISH AND WILDLIFE AND
THEIR HABITATS. EXTENDS THE
WATER SHUT OFF MORATORIUM-
THROUGH DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST
OF THIS YEAR IT INCLUDES-
CODIFIED LANGUAGE THAT
ESTABLISHES PARAMETERS FOR
VARIOUS PROGRAMS AND ACTIVITIES
THAT HAVE COMMITTED FUNDING IN
FUTURE YEARS. INCLUDING BUT NOT
LIMITED TO MULTI BENEFIT NATURE
BASED SOLUTIONS EXTREME HEAT
COASTAL ADAPTATION AND
PROTECTION AND COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE CENTERS- AND FINALLY
EXPENSES ON SIDE OF THE NET
ENERGY METERING FUEL CELL
PROGRAM BY TWO YEARS FROM
DECEMBER. THROUGH DECEMBER OF
THIS YEAR TO DECEMBER. THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
WE'RE GOING ON TO THE NEXT
AVAILABLE EIGHTY ONE SIXTY TWO
THAT'S THE LABOR TRAILER BILL
THIS BILL ESTABLISHES THE
COMMUNITY ECONOMIC RESILIENCE.
OR SEARCH PROGRAM. AND
APPROPRIATE SIX HUNDRED MILLION
ONETIME ARCHITECTURAL PLANS TO
THE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT FOR IMPLEMENTATION
SERVICE DESIGNED TO BUILD AN
ACCIDENT EQUITABLE AND
SUSTAINABLE ECONOMIC RECOVERY
FROM THE IMPACTS OF KOBE
NINETEEN. ON CALIFORNIA'S
INDUSTRIES WORKERS AND
COMMUNITIES AND TO SUPPORT THE
STATE'S RECOVERY ON THE BILL
INCLUDE INVESTMENTS FOR
PLANNING GRANTS AS WELL AS
COMPETITIVE IMPLEMENTATION
GRANTS AWARDED BY THE STATE TO
REGIONAL ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
PROJECTS ON A ROLLING BASIS.
I'M THE NEXT IS AB SIXTY
GENERAL GOVERNMENT GENERAL. DOT
DISTILLATES FANS ON ACTIONS
PREVIOUSLY TAKEN BY THE
LEGISLATURE AS IT RELATES TO BE
WAIVERS FOR CARD ROOMS AND
THIRD PARTY PROVIDERS SUCH AS
REQUIRING THE GAMBLING CONTROL
COMMISSION TO REFUND ANY ANNUAL
FEES. ALREADY PAID FOR A STATE
PAID FOR A STATE GAMBLING
LICENSE THAT WE DO. BETWEEN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO JULY
SIXTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
AND TO RETURN ANY ANNUAL FEES
ALREADY PAID BY A THIRD PARTY
PROVIDER OF PROPOSITION PLAYER
SERVICES. THAT WERE GIVEN TO ME
SEPTEMBER FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
TWO JULY SIXTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THE WELFARE BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY STOP
RUNNING AGENCIES AND STATE
ENTITIES TO IDENTIFY EXISTING
STATE CONTRACTS WHICH COULD BE
REPLACED WITH CENTRALIZED
CONTRACTS FOR SHARED SERVICES-
AND LAUGHTER THIS BILL ALSO
AMENDS STATUTE TO INCREASED BY
SEVENTEEN MILLION THE IMAM. OUR
STATE PROJECT INFRASTRUCTURE
FUND TO BE OPERATING FUNDS OF
THE ASSEMBLY AND SENATE FOR
MODIFICATIONS TO THE WEST BANK
RELATED TO ME AX PROJECTS. I'M
MOVING ON TO EIGHTY ONE SIXTY
FIVE- THE BARGAINING UNIT SEVEN
EIGHT SIDE LETTER TRAINABLE
THIS BILL RATIFIES SIDE LETTERS
BETWEEN THE ADMINISTRATION AND
THE CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATION ALSO
KNOWN AS CS ON THE EIGHT. AND
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION
FIREFIGHTERS CAL FIRE LOCAL
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY ONE. I BILL
DO NOT TAKE EFFECT UNLESS FUNDS
ARE APPROPRIATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE. I'M MOVING TO A.
B. ONE SIXTY SIX THE CANNABIS
TRAVEL BY THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET INCLUDES THIRTY MILLION
GENERAL FUND FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF CANNABIS CONTROL TO MINISTER
OF LABOR AND DEFERRAL PROGRAM.
CONTINGENT UPON FUTURE
LEGISLATION THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES PARAMETERS FOR THAT
PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY REQUIRES
THE DEPARTMENT ACCOUNTS
CONTROLLED DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT A FEE WAIVER PROGRAM
BY JANUARY FIRST OF NEXT YEAR.
AND OF ALL OF THE DIFFERENT.
FOLLOWING YEAR JANUARY FIRST.
THIS BILL ALSO ESTABLISHES A
DEFINITION OF EQUITY APPLICANT
LICENSEE FOR THE PURPOSES OF
THIS PROGRAM. AND APPROPRIATES
TEN THOUSAND GENERAL FINDS THE
DEPARTMENT TO HELP IMPLEMENT
PROGRAM. WE NEED TO EIGHTY ONE
SIXTY SEVEN DECATUR TWELVE WELL
I'M JUST DON'T VERIFY THAT
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES CAN
EARN A PORTION IT FUNDING FOR
STUDENTS PARTICIPATING IN
INDEPENDENT STUDY BECAUSE A
COUPLE NINETEEN RELATED
QUARANTINE BEGINNING DAY ONE.
OR TWO- FOR TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. J. BASED CHARTER SCHOOLS
CAN ALSO EARN APPORTIONMENT FOR
STUDENTS IN INDEPENDENT STUDY
THAT ARE SUBJECT TO COVER
NINETEEN QUARANTINE WITHOUT
BEING REQUIRED TO SUBMIT A
REQUEST FOR FUNDING
DETERMINATION. IT CLARIFIES
THAT FOR THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO PLAYER LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES MAY OBTAIN SIGNED
INDEPENDENT STUDY MASTER
AGREEMENTS UP TO THIRTY DAYS
AFTER A STUDENT BEGINS AN
INDEPENDENT STUDY PROGRAM. THAT
EXTENDS THE AMOUNT OF TIME A
SUBSTITUTE TEACHER CAN PROVIDE
INSTRUCTION IN A CLASS FROM
THIRTY DAYS TO SIXTY DAYS AND
IT MAKES VERY TECHNICAL.
LOOTING UPDATES TO FEDERAL
AWARD BOX. EIGHTY ONE SIXTY
EIGHT HEALTH CARE- TRAVEL WELL
THIS BILL TEMPORARILY
AUTHORIZES REIMBURSEMENT BASED
ON ENROLLMENT RATHER THAN
ATTENDANCE AND UP TO SIXTEEN
ADDITIONAL PAID NON OPERATIONAL
DAYS FOR EMERGENCY CHILDCARE
BRIDGE PROVIDERS THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT FUNDED
AND AUTHORIZED THESE TYPES OF
ASSISTANCE FOR OTHER PROGRAMS-
CHILDCARE PROGRAMS BUT THE
BRIDGE PROGRAM WITH AN
INTENTION UNINTENTIONALLY
EXCLUDED. THIS BILL ADDRESSED.
ON THE NEXT BILL IS EIGHTY ONE
SIXTY NINE THE POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION WELL- DISPELS DAMAGES
THE HIGHER EDUCATION STUDENT
HOUSING GRANT PROGRAM TO
PROVIDE ONE TIME GRANTS. FOR
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY AND UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA TO CONSTRUCT STUDENT
HOUSING OR TO ACQUIRE AND
RENOVATE COMMERCIAL PROPERTIES
INTO STUDENT HOUSING FOR LOW
INCOME STUDENTS. IT ALSO
ESTABLISHES THE HIGHER.
TRANSFER TO OBJECTS TO SUPPORT
INCREASED CALIFORNIA RESIDENT
INVOLVEMENT AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA AND CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY. AND LASTLY
IMPLEMENTS VARIOUS CHANGES TO
IMPROVE STUDENT FINANCIAL AID
AND COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY. BOB
MOVING ONTO AV ONE SEVENTY ONE
THE HOUSE TRAILER FELL- SOME
NOTABLE HIGHLIGHTS ARE THIS
BILL CODIFIES THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES OR H.
CBS SPENDING PLAN AS APPROVED
BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. IT
PROVIDES A WHEN YOU'RE- THIS
DIDN'T STANDARDS OF MEDICAID
MANAGED CARE SERVICES. WHERE'S
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO CONDUCT AN
EVALUATION SUBJECT FROM
CORPORATION DETERMINE WHETHER
HOUSING SUPPORT SERVICES
BENEFIT MAY BE SUPPORTED IN THE
FUTURE AND LASTLY AT WORK RATE
SIX POINT FOUR MILLION FEDERAL
GRANT FUNDING FOR MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
SERVICES. DISORDER RESOURCES
IMPACTED BACK UP NINETEEN. I'M
MOVING TO EIGHTY ONCE IN HERE
IN SERVICES- DISPEL CREATES A
CENTER FOR DATA INSIGHT AND
INNOVATION. OTHER UNITS
SERVICES AGENCY CODIFIES THE
COMMUNITY CARE EXPANSION AFTER
PATHWAYS PROGRAMS IT CLARIFIES
FIND MATCHING REQUIREMENTS FOR
THE GUARANTEED INCOME PILOT
PROGRAM. THAT AUTHORIZES DATA
SHARING BETWEEN THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION FOR
CHILDREN'S FOOD BENEFITS. AND
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL MAKES
OTHER TECHNICAL AND CONFORMING
CHANGES. VOMITING ON TWO EIGHTY
ONE SEVENTY THREE PUBLIC
SAFETY. DISPEL PROHIBITS THE
BURNING OR POSSESSION OF A
LOADED FIREARM. WHAT INTO THE
STATE OFFICE BUILDING LOCATED
AT TEN TWENTY ONE- STREET IN
SACRAMENTO. THIS PROVISION
ALREADY EXISTS IN THE STATE
CAPITOL AND LEGISLATIVE LOST
OFFICES I THANK THE FIVE- THIS
LANGUAGE INSURERS AND THE SAME
RESTRICTIONS REGARDING FIREARMS
AND OTHER DEADLY WEAPONS BOB AS
THE OTHER BUILDINGS OCCUPIED BY
THE LEGISLATURE APPLIED TO THIS
NEW BUILDING. AND I'M MOVING TO
EIGHTY ONE SEVENTY FOUR THE
TRANSPORTATION TRAILER FELL.
THIS BILL ALLOWS THE DEPARTMENT
OF MOTOR VEHICLES TO CONTINUE
IMPLEMENTING EFFICIENT. ITS
PROCESSES MORE EFFICIENT AND
REDUCE THE NEED FOR IN PERSON
OFFICE VISITS IT ALSO CHANGES
CONFORMING STATE LOTS OF
FEDERAL LAW REGARDING MOTOR
CARRIERS. I'M EIGHTY ONE
SEVENTY FIVE WHICH IS A HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS TRAIN ABOUT-
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
ACTS INCLUDED A TEN BILLION
DOLLAR HOUSING PACKAGE TO
PROMOTE AND MAINTAIN STABLE
HOUSING. ON THREE ADDITIONAL
EXPANDED RENTAL ASSISTANCE FOR
CLOSURE PREVENTION MORTGAGE
ASSISTANCE AND FIRST TIME HOME.
INVESTMENTS BUT ALSO INCLUDED
ESTES. PACKAGE OF TWELVE
BILLION OVER TWO YEARS AS THE
JUDGE STATED EARLIER THIS BILL
MAKES AMENDMENTS TO HOUSING
PROVISIONS VERIFYING THE INTENT
IN CRACKING DROPPING ERAS OF
OUR LANGUAGE. IN ADDITION THIS
BILL AND INCLUDES A PARTY TO
PROVIDE EMERGENCY HOMELESS
HOMELESSNESS SHELTER AND
SERVICES AT CAL EXPO AND
APPROPRIATE THIRTY MILLION A
ONE TIME LABOUR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FINES FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS. STRATEGIC
ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS FOCUSED ON
THAT CONSTRUCTION ALTERATION
AND REPAIR PROJECTS AS REPAIRS.
ONE FORTY. I'M MOVING ON TO
EIGHTY ONE SEVENTY SIX SMALL
BUSINESS TRAVEL THIS BILL MAKES
TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING
CHANGES TO VARIOUS GRANT
PROGRAMS ADMINISTERED BY THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND BUSINESS
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT ALSO NOT AS GOOD AS
INCLUDING THE SMALL BUSINESS
COVERT NINETEEN LATE BACKGROUND
A CALIFORNIA BUSINESS SAYS
MICHAEL BUT MICRO BUSINESS SAYS
KOBE NINETEEN ONLY AROUND AND
THE CALIFORNIA MANUSCRIPT
PROGRAM THIS BILL ALSO MAKES
TECHNICAL FIXES TO THE HOMELESS
HIRING CREDIT THE NEW STUDIO
CONSTRUCTIONS ON PRODUCT THE
GLOBAL EXPERIENCE TO PROGRAM.
AND THE PROGRAM IS ADOPTED AS
PART OF THE CHANGE IN THE
BUDGET THAT CHANGES HOW SALES.
TAX ON USED VEHICLES ARE
COLLECTED. AS IT MOVING TO ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN PUBLIC SAFETY
RELATED TO PARTS. WHICH IS OUR
LAST WELL- THIS BILL CODIFIES
THE GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
WHICH PROVIDES THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH THE NECESSARY AUTHORITY
TO CONTINUE OFFERING REMOTE
CIVIL PROCEEDINGS UNTIL JANUARY
THIRTY FIRST OF NEXT YEAR. BY
ALLOWING FOR CONTENT. BUT
PROCEEDINGS TRANSPORTS ME AWAY
FROM THE DELAYS CAUSED BY THE
PANDEMIC AND ADDRESS BACKLOGS
WHILE ALSO PROMOTING EQUITY. BY
USING TECHNOLOGY TO PROVIDE
SAFE AND TIMELY ACCESS FOR
CIVIL COURT PROCEEDINGS. THIS
BILL ALSO REQUIRES IT THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO SUBMIT A
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR AND THE USE OF
REMOTE TECHNOLOGY IT'S ABOUT
ACTION BY THE TRANSPORTS- BY
JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. THE BILL ALSO INCREASES
THE FEES FOR TRANSCRIPTS
PREPARED BY A COURT REPORTER-
ELIMINATES VARIOUS TYPES OF
CRIMINAL ADMINISTRATIVE. LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FOR INDIVIDUALS
WERE ARRESTED PROSECUTED OR
CONVICTED OF A CRIME. IT MAKES
THE UNPAID BALANCE OF MANY
COURT IMPOSED COSTS FOR THESE
BE TYPED IN AN ENFORCEABLE AND
COLLECTIBLE IN SHORT TAT
INCURRED IN THE PAST BU HE'S
HE'S COME A LONGER BE
COLLECTED- AND LAUGHTER THIS
BELOW WHAT ELIMINATES
ADMINISTRATIVE FEES FOR FELONY
OR MISDEMEANOR DIVERSION
RESTITUTION COLLECTION. AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TESTING. BUT
THAT'S- THOSE ARE R. SIXTEEN
BUDGET BILLS- AND AGAIN AS
STATED I'M I'M I'M GOING TO MY
COLLEAGUES AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
RESPOND TO ANY OF THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU MISLI
REALLY APPRECIATED- YOU DID
THAT IN RECORD TIME- I IMAGINE
THAT MY `LEAGUES
QUESTION OR TWO. SO LET ME SEE
YES SENATOR LAYER GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MADAM
CHAIR- EVEN THOUGH I'VE STUDIED
THESE WHERE SOME THINGS ARE
STILL CONFUSING BECAUSE THE
WATER RESILIENCE SEASON ONE BUT
THE THREE YEAR DROUGHT PACKAGES
IN ANOTHER I THINK IT'S IN ONE
FIFTY FIVE THEN MY QUESTION FOR
FINANCES. THAT THE DROUGHT
HAPPENS TO BE RIGHT NOW BUT THE
DROP MONEY IS A YEAR FROM NOW.
AND THERE ARE VARIOUS PROJECTS
THAT WERE CONTEMPLATED. SUCH AS
THE ONE I REFERENCE THIS
MORNING IN ANOTHER MEETING. THE
THERE ARE TWO HUGE RESERVOIRS
IN SOUTHERN MONTEREY COUNTY- I
THINK IT'S A HUNDRED DIST.
BETWEEN THEM A 1-001-005-0000
ACRE FEET AND ONE'S AT 9% ONCE
AT 14% AND THE VALVES AT THE
BOTTOM OF THE RESERVOIRS ARE
BROKEN THAT IS A DROUGHT PACKED
THAT IS A DROUGHT PROJECT BUT
THIS MONEY COULDN'T BE ACCESSED
FOR TWELVE MONTHS. AND
THEREFORE. MR MAGUIRE'S
DISTRICT HAS FORT BRAGG IN
MENDOCINO THEIR PLACES
THROUGHOUT THE CENTRAL COAST
THAT AREN'T ON THE DELTA THAT
HAVE THIS AND YET THE MONEY IS
A YEAR AWAY. MY QUESTION IS IF
THE CRISIS CONTINUES TO BE A
CUTE. FOR THE FINANCE
DEPARTMENT CONSIDERED
DEFICIENCY LETTER OR SOMETHING
THAT ALLOWS THIS MONEY TO BE
USED FOR THE CRISIS THAT WE'RE
FACING NOW. BUT ISN'T BUDGETED
FOR A YEAR FROM NOW. THANK YOU
FOR THAT QUESTION I MEAN I
WOULD JUST NOTE THAT THERE IS
MULTIPLE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
CURRENT YEAR AS WELL AS THE OUT
YEARS BUT I WILL TURN THIS
QUESTION OVER TO MY COLLEAGUES-
SERGIO ANGULAR. MORE DETAILS IN
REGARDS TO THE SPECIFIC PART OF
FINDING YOUR YOUR- ASKING ABOUT.
IT SURE NUMBER THIRTY- I GO
WITH THE PART OF FINANCE WHICH
IS THAT THE CLARIFY SO THE
WATER IS GOING TO DROP OFF
PACKAGES ABOUT FIVE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS. IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO THERE'S THREE POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS A LITTLE
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY IS
ACTUALLY PROGRAM IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. AND- SO WE
STRATEGICALLY PROGRAM THE
DOLLARS WHERE- THE MAJORITY
GOOD DROUGHT TOLERANCE UP
ALREADY AND IN THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUDGET. NOW ONE OF
THE NUMBER THAT WE ADDED IN THE
JUNE BUDGET WE HAD A CONTROL
SECTION- THAT ALL RIGHT THAT
ADDITIONAL TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS- FOR UNANTICIPATED
DROUGHT EMERGENCY. SO WE HAVE
SIMILAR TO LIKE A SUPPLEMENTAL
APPROPRIATION BUT THAT WAS
ACTUALLY GET CALLED OUT WITHIN
THE JUNE BUDGET FOR THAT
INITIAL TWENTY FIVE MILLION SO.
THEY CAN THEY'RE NEEDED THERE'S
ADDITIONAL. FUNDING WE CAN TAP
INTO THEIR CLASS JUST
CLARIFYING IT ABOUT THREE POINT
FIVE BILLION THAT WE DID
PROGRAM- FOR TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. NOT NOT SURE WHICH
SPECIFIC PART OF FUNDING YOU'RE
REFERENCING BUT THERE IS A- AS
A POTENTIAL MAIL A PROGRAM- BUT
I. LOOKED AT THE BREAK DOWN OF
THE DEFERRED PROGRAMS THAT WERE
LISTED I DON'T HAVE IT RIGHT IN
FRONT OF ME RIGHT NOW IT'S IN
ONE OF THESE. THEN IT FOR LOTS
OF DIFFERENT THINGS THAT MIGHT
BE. OF THE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT ACT THE THERE'S A
WHOLE HOST OF THINGS THAT ARE
IN THAT BUT TARGETED TOWARD THE
DROUGHT EMERGENCY SEEMS VERY
NARROW. THERE WAS A SPECIFIC
ITEM. THAT HAPPENED TO DO A
CENTRAL COAST DROP RESILIENCY
THAT GOT PUT IN THE OUT YEAR.
END AND SO WHAT I'M DRIVING AT.
IS I MEAN THERE'S AN INJECTION
WELL AT WATER RECYCLING IN
MONTEREY WHERE THERE. REALLY
STUCK IN THE STATE IS ABOUT TO
ORDER THEM TO CUT MORE. ARE
THEY COULD GET MORE WATER THEY
COULD UPGRADE WELLS IN SANTA
CRUZ THAT WOULD ALLOW THEM TO
GET MORE WATER. THE BIG. BASIN
FIRE. DIST DESTROYED THE WAR
ALONG FOR BIG BASS WATER. IN
THOSE PEOPLE TO REBUILD OR
THEIR ARE ABOUT OF ONE AND
THERE'S A PART CAN. THAT NEEDS
TO GO THERE'S THE VALVES IN THE
PROJECTS THAT- IF THE SALINAS
RIVER AND THE RED. ARE WAS JUST
REFER TO. AND YOU LOOK AT THESE
HEIGHTS. YOU HAVE NO WISH. THE
DOES COME OF PROUD. APPLY FOR
TWO AND YET THEY'RE GOING TO
RUN OUT A WALL. AND SO WHAT I'M
LOOKING AT IS NOT THAT THERE'S
A LOT OF MONEY THERE FOR A LOT
OF DIFFERENT LINE ITEMS TELL ME
HOW IT'S GOING TO BE REDIRECTED
TO THE DROUGHT AND MEET THE
NEEDS THAT ARE. THAT ARE URGENT
AND GOING ON RIGHT NOW. YEAH
IT'S ALL JUST GOING TO A FEW
SPECIFIC POP THE FUNDING THAT
WE DO HAVE A TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. FOR DROUGHT EARLIER THIS
YEAR WE DID FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS- PER SMALLER
SUPPLIERS- AND URBAN WHILE
WATER MAGIC GRANTS.
SPECIFICALLY TO FOCUS PURELY ON
VALUE ISSUES. ON SIGMA WITH THE
MONEY WE'RE ADDING NOW AND THE
JUNE BUDGET THAT'S A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY. FIVE YOU
COULD LIVE A CORE- SIGMA GRAFT-
SWEEP IN ANOTHER PROGRAM WHICH
WE KNOW ALSO HELPS- DURING
DROUGHT ESPECIALLY AND FORMER
SIDE. SO THAT'S UP FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO SO. WE CAN. KIND OF
SHOW YOU A BREAKDOWN OF ALL THE
TWENTY ONE NO. I GET SOME OF
THAT BREAK DOWN I MEAN I
HAPPENED TO BE IN THE CABINET
WHEN SIGNAL WAS ADOPTED CIGNA
IS IT NECESSARILY A DRAFT
PROGRAM. I STRONGLY SUPPORTED
ONE WHAT'S IN THERE BUT- BUT-
THE RECYCLING IF. IT WERE- AND
THERE WAS ONE OTHER ISSUE THAT.
OUR RISK RAISE CENTER WHITE
HOUSE IS SPEAKING MY YEAR.
WHICH IS THE THING THAT
PROVIDES WATER IN AN EMERGENCY
QUICKER THAN ANYTHING ELSE IS A
WATER RECYCLING. AND WHEN THE
WATER BOND WAS ADOPTED IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN. ARE THERE WAS
EIGHT HUNDRED AND FIFTY I
BELIEVE MILLION DOLLARS-
SUBSCRIBE IMMEDIATELY ACROSS
THE STATE. AND IT PROVIDES
WATER. IN IT IN A VERY. A
DISPERSED MANNER ALL ACROSS THE
STATE IS IN. D. NEGOTIATIONS
ARE LET GO SHE ASIANS BUT THE
NUMBER GOT DROPPED AND THEN.
THERE IS ONE THING THAT WOULD
PROVIDE A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
WATER AND IT IS NOT THE
FEATURED IN A MAJOR WAY IN THIS
AND SO- I'M COGNIZANT OF THE
FACT THIS IS A DEAL. IT'S DONE.
HOME OR PASS THE AMENDMENT
DEADLINE BUT THESE ARE NEEDS
THAT ARE REAL AND ARE GOING
AWAY AND SO- I DON'T THINK ANY
OF THE SIGMA MONEY'S GOING TO
GO TO DROUGHT RELIEF. BUT SO I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN WORK ON THIS AND THAT
THERE'S SOME KIND OF.
COMMITMENT THAT IF ALL THESE
ARE IN CATEGORIES THAT DON'T
WORK FOR WATER DISTRICTS ACROSS
THE STATE. OR CITIES OR
COUNTIES THAT ARE RUNNING OUT
OF WATER. THERE'S A COMMITMENT
TO WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND WORK WITH THE DISTRICTS AND
DO A DEFICIENCY LETTER OR
WHATEVER IT TAKES. BECAUSE I
KNOW SOME OF IT THAT WAS MOST
IMPORTANT TO ME GOT PUT ME OUT
OF HERE WHEN THE DROUGHT IS NOW
AND THAT'S THE THING THAT
TRIGGERED THIS. BUT BUT IT'S
JUST I'M LOOKING FOR. A DESIRE
TO WORK TOGETHER BECAUSE PEOPLE
IF WHAT I THINK YOU KNOW WE'RE
NOT GONNA RAIN STORM THAT'S
REMOTELY SIGNIFICANT TILL
NOVEMBER COULD BE DECEMBER. AND
PEOPLE OR IT'S JUST GOING TO
GET PROGRESSIVELY WORSE. AND
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE NEEDS NOW
AND IT HITS LOWER INCOME MORE
REMOTE COMMUNITIES FIRST. AND
THAT IS JUST GOING TO BE AN
ISSUE SO I'VE SAID MY PIECE.
BUT I'M GONNA BE LOOKING. FOR
COOPERATE ON THIS PATH IF WE
MOVE INTO THIS AND PEOPLE NEED
HELP. THE PARDON ME CALL AND-
ARE VERY SURE SENATOR NIELSEN
AND- SENATOR GROVE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR DIRECTED TO FINANCE.
MY COLLEAGUE. FROM THE SANTA
CLARA VALLEY WAS JUST ASKING A
NUMBER OF QUESTIONS THAT ARE
APPLICABLE AND I DON'T THINK
WE'VE GOT THOSE ANSWERED THUS
FAR SPECIFICALLY ENOUGH. WHAT
THE LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO KNOW
FOR SURE FROM FINANCE FROM THE
GOVERNOR IS THAT AS WE THEN
AFTER THE BUDGET. THAT DOES
WONDERS WILL BE TIMELY EXPANDED.
A INVESTIGATION DONE BY. PBS A
LITTLE OVER A YEAR AGO
DISCLOSED THAT SUBSTANTIAL
DOLLARS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
PUT IN THE BUDGET FOR WILDLAND
MANAGEMENT. FIRE PREVENTION WAS
NOT SPENT. WITH WITH HEALTH.
AND I'M CURIOUS AS TO WHO THE
AUTHORITY WAS THAT MADE THAT
DETERMINATION. BUT THEN WE HAD
SOME INSIGHT EARLY THIS YEAR AS
THE BUDGET WAS SUBMITTED. SOME
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
WAS DIRECTED FOR THESE PURPOSES
FOR SOMEONE OF LAND MANAGEMENT
TO PREVENT THESE CATACLYSMIC
FIRES. HOWEVER THE CABINET IN
THE LANGUAGE ACTUALLY SAID.
THAT IT HAD TO BE DETERMINED AS
NEEDED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NOW I'D- BEEN LED TO
UNDERSTAND SUCH LANGUAGE IS NO
LONGER IN THE BUDGET DIRECTOR
OF FINANCE IS THERE ANY
LANGUAGE. IN THE BUDGET. THAT
WOULD ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE OR ANYTHING AND
EXECUTIVE BRANCH TO THE
RESOURCES AGENCY TO NOT EXPAND
THE DOLLARS THAT WE HAVE THEN
APPROPRIATED. AND PROVIDED FOR
IN THE BUDGET IS THERE ANY
LANGUAGE THAT GIVES THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT DISCRETION-
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
CENTER IN THE US AND I'LL TURN
THAT OVER TO SERGIO REGULAR FOR
SOME DETAILS. IF THEY'RE
GENERALLY PART OF FINANCE- SO
YOU'RE PREGNANT EARLIER THIS
YEAR THAT WAS- THE THOUGHT THAT
WE HAVE OR WE WERE PRETTY SEVEN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. AND THEN
WE WOULD PROVIDE THE TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE WITH
AUTHORITY TO ACCELERATE.
HOWEVER IN THIS BUDGET I WILL
PRESENT TO YOU NOW WE'RE
ACTUALLY APPROPRIATING THE
ENTIRE AMOUNT TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. FOUR NINE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN
THIS CURRENT FISCAL YEAR. AND
THERE IS NO. ADDITIONAL
AUTHORITY THAT WE HAVE TO THE
MOVE THAT BACK- WITHOUT ANY
KIND OF FUTURE LEGISLATION. AND
SO THAT THAT- KIND OF- KIND OF
THOUGHT THAT WE HAD BACK IN
JUNE. IF. NOT WE'LL MOVE
FORWARD WITH ITS BUDGET. WELL
THAT THAT CERTAINLY IS HELPFUL
SIR AND- I KNOW WE ALL WILL
APPRECIATE THAT. SOMEWHAT OF A
CONCERN THEN IS THAT THIS
BUDGET IS PROVIDING MONEY OVER
SEVERAL YEARS. AND THE LACK OF
SPECIFICITY IS OF CONCERN. SO
HOW WILL THIS BE MONITORED AND
REPORTED TO THE LEGISLATURE I
DON'T WANT I WOULD COME BACK
NEXT YEAR AS THE BUDGET IS
SUBMITTED AND SAY WELL THIS IS
WHERE WE'RE AT NOW THIS IS HOW
MUCH WE SPENT. WE NEED TO HAVE
SOME REGULAR UPDATING OF THE
EXPENDITURES IN THE ABORTION
MUCH AROUND CALIFORNIA TO THESE
NECESSARY PROJECT WHICH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE SANTA CLARA
VALLEY JUST OUTLINED A NUMBER
OF IN THE AREA THAT HE-
REPRESENTS AND INDEED THE POST.
AND OTHER SENATORS FROM THE
NORTH IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
THEY HAVE THEIR OFFICES WELL WE
NEED TO KNOW THAT THOSE ARE
BEING ATTENDED. TO WHAT
ASSURANCE CAN YOU GIVE US THE
MONEY THAT WE WOULD VOTE AND
THIS BUDGET. IS ACTUALLY GOING
TO BE TIMELY LED OUT. INTO THE
COMMUNITIES AND I SEE THAT WE
DO HAVE SOME SPECIFIC THAT
SPECIFIC. PURPOSES OR ENTITIES
THAT MONIES CAN GO TO. BUT HOW
WOULD YOU KEEP TRACK OF THAT
AND REPORT IT TO THE
LEGISLATURE. A THIRD PARTY
FINANCE SO SPECIFICALLY ON THE
WILDFIRE AND FOR RELIEF
PACKAGE. WE ACTUALLY HAVE-
CREDIBLE LANGUAGE I WAS
INCLUDED THAT- MANDATES ANNUAL
REPORTING- FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION TO THE
LEGISLATURE- ON ALL OF THE WALL
PART BENCHERS. AS A PART OF
THAT THERE WILL BE ANY
REPORTING OVER I BELIEVE THAT
THE NEXT FIVE YEARS. WATCH THE
TRAILER BILL AUTHORIZED. THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA THAT ARE
LITERALLY OUT OF WATER. IS
MONEY HAVE PROVIDED HERE TO ALL
THE S. TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
MONEY OF MONEY FOR. WATER TO BE
DELIVERED POTABLE WATER TO SOME
OF THESE COMMUNITIES SO THEY
CAN JUST LITERALLY SURVIVE.
WE'VE BEEN HAVING THE KIND OF
FACILITATE IN OUR OWN DISTRICTS
DOWN EXCHANGES OF WATERFORD
CITY I'VE GOT GROOVE ONE CITY
TO ANOTHER CITY. WHAT WHAT'S
THE PROVISIONS IN THE BUDGET
AND THE INTENT OF FINANCE TO
ENSURE THAT MONIES THAT ARE
NEEDED JUST FOR LIVING. ARE
GOING TO BE DIRECTED TIMELY.
THROUGH AND THROUGH OUR AGENCY
WHAT DEPARTMENT WOULD IT BE-
YES. HELLO AGAIN SIR JOHN NEVER
PART OF FINANCE- THERE'S A
COUPLE DEPARTMENT THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY- PROVIDE SUPPORT
THERE AND WE ACTUALLY DID
INCLUDE FUNDING AND- THAT THEY
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
BUDGET FOR EMERGENCY DRINKING
WATER NEEDS- AND THEN I SPOKE
TO A LITTLE BIT EARLIER ON. A
CONTROLLED SECTION THAT WE DID
ADD AND- DATES JUNE BUDGET THAT
PROVIDED ADDITIONAL AUTHORITY
FOR THESE TYPES OF EMERGENCY
DRINKING WATER NEEDS AND
CALLAWAY HAS ALSO DOES PLAY A
ROLE- AND- ALSO THROUGH CDA
WHICH THEY COULD AUTHORIZE FOR
SOME OF THE- EMERGENCY DRINKING
WATER NEEDS THAT SO THERE'S
KIND OF MULTIPLE- VENUES AND
DEPARTMENT. THAT. BECAUSE THE
POOR LOCAL COMMUNITIES OR NEED.
THE WILD FIRES ARE OCCURRING
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. NORTH
SOUTHEAST WEST THE VALLEYS. IT
ISN'T JUST THE NORTH AND THE
SOUTH- BURNING WHEN THE SANTA
ANA WINDS BLOW OR WHEN WE HAVE
THESE HEAVY FIRES UP IN THE
NORTH. SO. WHAT F. WHAT'S YOUR
BUDGET AND MAYBE ONE SEVENTY.
AND IT SAYS THE GOAL IS TO
TREAT FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ACRES A YEAR. WELL HAS THE
RESOURCES AGENCY PROVIDED A
SCHEDULE. AND I KNOW SOME OF
OUR MEMBERS ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE ADJACENT
DISTRICT IN THE NORTH HAS DONE
A LOT OF INVENTORYING WORK OF
FOUR SHOVEL READY PROJECTS. THE
RESOURCES AGENCY. HAVE THEY
DONE THAT AS WELL. IDENTIFIED
THE NECESSARY AND HIGHEST
PRIORITY PROJECTS FOR MONIES TO
BE DIRECTED TO FOR A WHILE AND
MANAGEMENT. SO WHAT THEY ARE
ALTHOUGH THE COUPLE THINGS AS
FAR AS THE EARLY ACTION PACKAGE
THAT- WE PASSED EARLIER THIS
YEAR WE'VE ACTUALLY WARDED- 85%
OF THAT FUNDING WE HAVE PROJECT
LISTS. THAT WE HAVE THAT WE
COULD SHARE OF ALL THE
DIFFERENT PROJECTS THAT WERE
HIGH PRIORITY BACK RECEIVED
FUNDING UNDER THAT- AND AS PART
OF THIS ADDITIONAL AUGMENTATION
WE'RE PROVIDING THAT NINE
HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS- I THINK THAT
PERSPECTIVE THAT WE HAVE IS. TO
DO LARGER MORAL LANDSCAPE SCALE
TYPE PROJECTS- THAT COULD
PROVIDE FUNDING TO THE SUPPORT
OF THAT PROJECT FOR A FOR A
COUPLE YEARS AND SO I KNOW
THAT- YOU KNOW CAL FIRE AND-
AND MYSTERY AGENCIES- WORK WITH-WITH THE REGION'S WORK WITH THE
LOCALS. WHO YOU KNOW ARE
PRINTING OTHER PLANS TO
IDENTIFY THE DIFFERENT TYPES OF
PROJECTS AND PART OF THE
FUNDING THAT WE HAVE HERE IS
ALSO FOR A PROGRAM THAT IS PART
OF CONSERVATION RUNS. TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
LOCALS TO DEVELOP THOSE A
PIPELINE OF PROJECTS AND SO YOU
KNOW STATEWIDE APPROACH
ORIGINALLY LEAD SO I THINK
THAT'S THAT'S A BIG ASPECT OF
THIS. RULE THAT WE HAVE. WELL
LAST. QUESTION THEN FOR THE
MOMENT. THE MANY THAT HAVE BEEN
SO DECIMATED. IN PAST DISASTERS
AND I'M THINKING PARTICULAR
PARADISE OR IN FACT THE ORVILLE
DAM SPILLWAY FAILURE. AGENCIES
HAVE COME TO THE HELP OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. THE STATE WAS
PARTICULARLY HELPFUL TO
PARADISE. AT LEAST AT THE FRONT
END. ARE YOU POKER SING ON
THOSE MOST NEEDED AND TIRES
PRIORITY AREAS THAT NEED SOME
HELP TO ALLOW THE CITIZENS TO
REESTABLISH THEIR COMMUNITIES
THEIR OWN LIVELIHOODS AND HOMES.
I MEAN IF I GET THAT QUESTION
OVER T SERGIO- FOR FURTHER
DETAILS. I THINK YOU IF YOU
EVER THINK THAT TYPE OF PROJECT
THAT WE WOULD FIND UNDER THE
UNDER THE ESTOPPEL WE ARE
FOCUSED ON KIND OF MORE OF
THOSE YOU KNOW HI I'M FIRE RISK
AREAS AFTER THAT IS- ONE OF THE
KEY FOCUSES OF. THE CRITERIA
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT THE GRAPH
OF PROGRAMS WITH MR. I WOULD
THEN ASK. THE MANAGER I'LL-
DEFER AFTER THIS QUESTION. THE
TOP KIND OF A LITTLE BIT AGO
ABOUT MAYBE HAVING A SCHEDULE
OF THINGS THAT YOU WERE GOING
TO BE SPENDING MONEY ON. COULD
YOU MAKE A COMMITMENT TO THE
LEGISLATORS THAT YOU WOULD
KINDLY PROFFERED THOSE
DOCUMENTS OF YOUR PRIORITIES TO
THE LEGISLATURE SO THAT WE AT
LEAST COULD THEN REVIEW THEM
AND- HAVE OUR INPUT. AS TO WHAT
WE THINK BOTH PRIORITY SHOULD
BE. BUT I THINK IF YOU'RE GOING
BACK TO MY EARLIER COMMENT
WHERE A PART OF THIS PRINTER
BILL ACTUALLY REQUIRES US TO
REPORT ANNUALLY ON ALL THE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF PROJECTS- TO
THE LEGISLATURE THAT WE ARE
FUNDING WITH. SOME OF THE
PROJECTS- AND JUST SOME SOME OF
THE OUTCOMES AND SO THAT WILL
BE PART OF OUR ANNUAL REPORTING
TO THE LEGISLATURE WHERE YOU
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE
TO VIEW- ALL THE DIFFERENT
PROJECTS THAT ARE BEING
AWARDED- WITHIN THIS PACKAGE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK
YOU SENATOR NELSON LET MELIST
TOO I HAVE HERE I HAVE A CENTER
GROVE SENATOR DOLLY SENATOR COM
LOCKER SENATOR DRAWS SO.
SENATOR IN. NASSERITE CASKEY.
K. WORKERS CAME IN OKAY.
SENATOR GROSS THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I DO- OKAY I'LL KEEP MY
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS BRIEF
BECAUSE I KNOW THERE ARE A LOT
OF MY ACCEPT THEM BUT I DO HAVE
SEVERAL QUESTIONS AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR HAVING A FIVE.
BUT AN EIGHTY ONE SEVENTY THE
WILDFIRE FUNDING EITHER FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOR THE
L. A. L. IN OUR FIRST OUR
FORESTS ARE BURNING UP ALL
AROUND US AND IT'S EVIDENT THAT
STATE AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS
AND- NEED TO DO A LOT MORE TO
PREVENT WILDFIRE LAND
MANAGEMENT THINGS LIKE THAT. AS
A STATE WE HAVE A GOAL TO TREAT
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ACRES PER YEAR AND HOW MANY
ACRES DO YOU ESTIMATE CAN BE
TREATED WITH THE FUNDS PROVIDED
IN THIS BUDGET I'M JUST YOU
KNOW I DON'T. WE DON'T SEE
BILLS LIKE HOW MUCH IT COSTS TO
TREAT THESE ACRES AND SERVE
DOES ANYBODY HAVE AN IDEA- HOW
MUCH OF A- IT WILL COST TO
TREAT THESE FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACRES AND IS THERE
ENOUGH MONEY IN THE BUDGET FOR
THAT. THANK YOU SENATOR GROVER
THAT QUESTION- I'LL TURN IT
OVER TO BECOME MORE OR RESPOND.
I DON'T WANT TO PUT IN A
FINANCE THANKS FOR THE
QUESTION- UNFORTUNATELY THAT
THAT GOOGLE THE ACRES IT'S HARD
TO PREDICT BECAUSE SO MUCH OF
THAT GOING OUT IN- GRANT
DOLLARS BUT I CAN ASSURE THAT-
IN. TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY WE
DIFFERENT INITIAL NUMBERS IN
BETWEEN A HUNDRED AND FIVE
THOUSAND ACRES. I WE DON'T YET
HAVE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUT WE
EXPECTED TO INCREASE
DRAMATICALLY BUT THE EARLY
ACTION PLANS THAT JUST CAME IN
AND THEN INCREASE FROM THERE
WITH THIS ADDITIONAL FUNDING-
OKAY. THANK YOU M. AN ON AGAIN
ON EIGHTY ONE SEVENTY AT GIVEN
THE STATE'S COMMITMENT TO A
100% CLEAN ENERGY BY TWENTY
FORTY FIVE THERE WAS FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS A ONE TIME
EXPENDITURES IN THE BUDGET THAT
WE HAD IN JUNE AND- I THINK WE
DID THAT OR AT LEAST IT WAS MY
UNDERSTANDING WE DID THAT
BECAUSE A LOT OF TIMES WHEN WE
DO THINGS LIKE THIS- IT CAUSES
OUR RATES FOR CALIFORNIANS
UNDER UTILITY BILLS TO GO UP
THERE'S ADDITIONAL COST AND
RATE PAYERS. THIS FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS WOULD HAVE
ELIMINATED SOME OF THAT FOR
RATE PAYERS THAT PAY THE
HIGHEST UTILITYRATES- ALMOST
IN THE NATION AND- I NOTICED
THAT MANY IS GONE NOW THAT THIS
BUDGET TROLL DELETES THAT
FUNDING IS THERE. A REASON FOR
THAT. SENATOR GROPED FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION FOR. WHAT WAS
THAT- THE ITEM. AND IT WAS IN
EIGHTY ONE SEVENTEEN IT WAS ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND WHICH
INCLUDED THE JUNE BUDGET FOR
CLEAN ENERGY PROJECTS- SEEM
LIKE A PRUDENT INVESTMENT BUT
THAT MANY IS NOW GONE. WITH
THIS BUDGET TRAILER BILL SO I
WAS JUST CURIOUS WHY. AND
NUMBER AFTER. FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION FOR CLIMATE ADAPTATION
PROJECTS. MMHM OKAY- IF THAT
WAS PART OF THE TRANSPORTATION-
PACKAGE THAT WAS PART OF THE
JUNE- DEAL HOWEVER IT WAS
CONTINGENT ON AN ALLOCATION
SCHEDULE BEING PROVIDED BY THE
LEGISLATURE BY OCTOBER TENTH-
AND IF THERE IS NO LEGISLATION
ENACTED THOSE FUNDS WILL REVERT
BACK SO THAT WAS PART OF A
BROADER. TRANSPORTATION
PACKAGE- THAT IS STILL UNDER
DISCUSSION SO DISCUSSIONS ARE
SURROUND SURROUNDING- HIGH
PRIORITY TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS ARE STILL UNDER WAY
AND HOPE TO COME BACK TO THAT
IN JANUARY. THANK YOU MA'AM
THANK YOU FOR THAT RESPONSE AND
ANOTHER QUESTION I HAD AN
EIGHTY ONE SEVENTY AS WELL THE
BUDGET BILL JUNIOR IS COVERT
NINETEEN TESTING HOW THE EIGHT
HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL FUNDING- FOR
SCHOOL BASEMENT COVERED
NINETEEN TESTING BE ALLOCATED.
O BASED ON SCHOOL POPULATION
IS THERE A FORMULA IS IT JUST
GOING TO GO TO CERTAIN
COUNTIES- YEAH THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION I'M GONNA TURN IT
OVER TO ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES IN
EDUCATION UNIT FOR SOME MORE
DETAILS. THANK YOU. HI THIS IS
WHAT I LOOK FOR MONDAY GUESS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THIS IS PROBABLY A- A
CALIFORNIA. DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH QUESTION- SO THE
EIGHT HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SEVEN
MILLION- THAT SAYING. HE WON
SEVENTY IS FOR- KOBE TESTING IN
SCHOOLS AND SO THIS FUNDING HAS
ALREADY BEEN MADE AVAILABLE TO-
ALL SCHOOLS AS OF THIS SPRING
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE- SO. THE
SCHOOLS HAVE TO- TAKE SOME-
THEY HAVE TO TAKE SOME A FEW
STEPS TO BE ABLE TO- ACCESS THE
FUNDING BUT- IT HAS BEEN MADE
AVAILABLE TO ALL HAVE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS CHARTER SCHOOLS- AS
WELL AS PRIVATE SCHOOLS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
INFORMATION ON AB ONE SEVENTY
ONE I THINK THIS WOULD BE HIS
HEALTH FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND- WHICH ENTITY WILL
DO THE INDEPENDENT NETWORK-
ADEQUACY ANALYSIS ON INTEGRATED
HOUSING SUPPORT SERVICES INTO
MEDIC COW. THANK YOU SENATOR
THAT'S ALSO A QUESTION OUT FOR
ME AGAIN WHEN I LOOK AT MY
TICKETS BUT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO THE EVALUATION THAT
YOUR- QUESTION IS ABOUT WILL BE
CONDUCTED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. OKAY
THANK YOU AND MY LAST QUESTION
IS ON AB ONE SIXTY TO THE
COMMUNITY ECONOMIC RESILIENCE
FUND GRANT CRITERIA- I'M JUST
CURIOUS WHO DETERMINES HOW OR
WHO IS DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTED BY COVERT NINETEEN
MEANS AND WHO'S ELIGIBLE FOR
THE GRANTS WHO DETERMINES THAT
I CAN'T FIND ANYTHING IN THE
LANGUAGE THAT. NAMES I AM. AN
IDIOT COMMITTEE A AGENTS FROM
SO JUST CURIOUS. THANK YOU FOR
THAT- CENTER GROVE I KNOW THAT
YOU'VE BEEN PARTICULARLY
INTERESTED IN THIS FIND- I'M
GONNA TURN THIS QUESTION OVER
TO MY COLLEAGUE PATRICK TOPPING
WHO HAS SOME. DETAILS THAT I
BELIEVE THE DEFINITION- AS WELL
THANK YOU. HI PATRICK TOPPING
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- SO THE
TREND IS DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY SO IN NINETEEN IS A
FEDERALLY DEFINED TERM AND IT'S
INCLUDING LANGUAGE TO ALIGN
WITH THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN
ACTING GUIDANCE. AS BEING
PROMULGATED- BUT THE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND MINISTER THE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
ADMINISTRATION RELEASED A
NOTICE FUNDING AVAILABILITY TO
DETERMINE EVERY REGION IN THE
U. S. AND AFFECT MY CODE AND SO
EVERYTHING. THESE FUNDS. OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TAKE THE TIME TO ANSWER MY
QUESTIONS I HOPE THEY WEREN'T
TOO LONG AND- I'LL TURN IT OVER
TO THE CHAIR AGAIN TO CALL ON
THAT ONE OF OUR OTHER. FIFTEEN
COLLEAGUES THAT HAS- MIKE UP.
THANK YOU SENATOR GROVE WHO MAY
GO TO SENATOR DOLLY. THANK YOU
ADAM CHARM I DON'T HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR FINANCE I HAVE
JUST I WANT TO RECAP ON. WHAT'S
HAPPENED OVER THE LAST YEAR I
SAID ON SEPT TWO AND- WE DID
THE EARLY ACTION FIRE MONEY.
AND WE WANTED TO GET THOSE THAT
MONEY OUT SO WE COULD ACTUALLY
DO PROJECTS IN OUR COMMUNITIES
TO HELP. FEND OFF WHICH WE KNEW
WAS COMING THE FIRE. AND TODAY
WE BURN ABOUT A MILLION ACRES
JUST IN MY DISTRICT ALONE. SO
DURING BEFORE THE BREAK THE
FIRES WERE STARTED BEFORE WE
ARE. RECESS AND WE PASSED MORE
LEGISLATION TO IN THE BUDGET
BILL AND WE TALKED ABOUT. THIS
BILL THE TRAILER BILL CLEAN UP
LEGISLATION FOR FIRE. SO OVER
THE BREAK I ACTUALLY DID SOME
RESEARCH IN BETWEEN WATCHING MY-
COMMUNITIES BURNED OUT. AND I
FOUND THAT THERE WAS FOUR
HUNDRED AND SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS WITH THE PROJECT AND I
HAVE THE LIST RIGHT HERE IN MY
HAND. AND IT'S NOT PROJECTS IN
MY DISTRICT IT'S PROJECTS ALL
OVER CALIFORNIA. THEY'RE IN
EVERYONE IN YOUR DISTRICT. I
MAY HAVE TREES YOU MAY HAVE
CHAPARRAL. BUT OUR COMMUNITIES
WILBUR IF WE DO NOT DO
SOMETHING WITH EDUCATION
MANAGER THESE ARE. MIND YOU
SHOVEL READY PROJECTS SO I
SUBMITTED THESE. LESS TO THE
BUDGET CHAIRS I SUBMITTED THEM
TO. THE SUB TWO MEMBERS I
SUBMITTED THEM TO THE PEOPLE
WHO MAKE THIS PLACE WORK. AND
I'M ON. THE WRONG SIDE OF THE
AISLE TO GET THINGS DONE
BECAUSE- EVEN THOUGH I
SUBMITTED ALL THESE PROJECTS.
IN THE BILITY GET THE MONEY ON
THE GROUND TO GET IT DONE. THIS
WILL HAPPEN. SO WE HAVE A
PROCESS THAT SET OUT THE WE ARE
IN A BUDGET HEARING TODAY. AND
WE'RE GONNA LISTEN TO THE
PUBLIC. AND WE'RE GONNA TAKE
THEIR TESTIMONY WHICH- I
BELIEVE DOESN'T MEAN ANYTHING
BECAUSE- IF I HAVE A LEGISLATOR
CAN'T GET. THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK ABOUT. IN A WAY TO AMEND
BILLS SO THAT WE ACTUALLY DO
SOMETHING ON HE GROUND I DON'T
KNOW HOW THE PUBLIC CAN EVER
INFLUENCES PLACE. TODAY I
WANTED TO SHARE SOME THOUGHTS
ABOUT. WHAT WE NEED TO DO AND I
WANT TO SHARE. WHAT WE FAILED
OUR STATE. WITH POLICY NUMBER.
ONE WHEN WE TALK ABOUT TREATING
A HALF A MILLION ACRES. THE CAL
FIRE FOLKS COUNT ACRES THAT'S
TREATED BETTER TIMBER HARVEST
PLANS WHICH PRIVATE COMPANIES
DO ON THEIR OWN LAND. WE ASKED
HIM THAT IN SUB TWO AND THEY
SAID THAT'S TRUE THAT'S
PROPERTIES THAT DIDN'T COST THE
STATE A DIME ACTUALLY WE MADE
MONEY OFF OF THEM. AND THAT'S
ABOUT THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ACRES. AS I'VE WATCHED MY CAN
SO WE WHEN WE REALLY TALK ABOUT
TREATING ACRES AND WHAT MONIES
WERE SPENDING ON IT THEY'RE
COUNTING ACRES THAT THEY DON'T
EVEN SPEND A DIME ON IS ARE
TREATED ACRES TOOK THE NARROW
IT DOWN TO LOOK AT ABOUT A
MONEY WE'RE SPENDING. ON ACRES
IT'S A LOT HIGHER. COST. SO I'M
ATTEMPTING TO TRY TO. GET
OBJECTS DONE FIRE SAFETY
PROJECTS DONE AROUND
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. SO WE DON'T BURN OUR
COMMUNITIES DOWN. NOW WE ALL
KNOW THAT THE EIGHTH WONDER OF
THE WORLD WAS ALMOST ON PAR
WHICH I CALL TAHOE. I REPRESENT
ALL OF LAKE TAHOE. AND WHEN THE
FIRE CAME OVER THE RIDGE. AND
INTO THE VALLEY THERE WAS A
FIRE BREAK THERE WE HAVE BEEN
DOING SOME FIRE BREAKS AROUND
THE LAKE IN THE LAST FIFTEEN
YEARS SINCE THE ANGORA FIRE. WE
WERE ABLE TO BACK FIRE AT THE
FIRE BREAKING ACTUALLY TURN THE
FIRE AND SAVE. LAKE TAHOE. CAN
YOU IMAGINE WHAT GREENVILLE
WOULD LOOK LIKE IF WE HAD A
FIRE SAFETY. AROUND THAT
COMMUNITY WE WOULD STILL HAVE A
COMMUNITY THERE. SO I HAVE
AMENDMENTS MADAM CHAIR THAT I
WANT TO PROPOSE I DON'T KNOW
HOW THIS PROCESS WORKS I'VE
NEVER DONE THIS BEFORE BUT I
HAVE AN IMAGE THAT I WANT. THE
BUDGET TO REFLECT THAT IF
THERE'S A PART OF A PROJECT
THAT IS AVAILABLE WHAT THAT
MEANS THAT SEQUEL A- NEPA
APPROVED PROJECTS. THAT WE FIND
THEM NOT. THROUGH CAL FIRE WHO
IS BUSY FIGHTING FIRE. OR IF IT
IS THROUGH CAL FIRE THAN THEY
HAVE TO GET THE FUNDS OUT. BY
THE PROP THE PROJECTS THAT ARE.
DEEPER AND SEEK A- SHOVEL READY
PROJECTS THAT WE FIND THEM.
THEY BE DEFENDED BY FEBRUARY
ONE JANUARY ONE OF NEXT YEAR SO
THAT THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
PLANNING THESE PROJECTS
ACTUALLY GET THE PEOPLE ON THE
GROUND GETTING DONE SO THAT.
NEXT YEAR OR NOT STARTING IN
JANUARY WE'RE STARTING OUT WE
HAVE THE MONEY IN THIS BUDGET
DOES NOT DIRECT THE POLICY TO
GET THOSE DONE SO I'VE
SUBMITTED THE MINUTES TO
EVERYONE YOUR DESK. THAT WE
SHOULD PUT IN THE LANGUAGE THAT
ALLOWS US TO GET THESE PROJECTS
DONE. I JUST I DON'T KNOW WHERE
ELSE TO GO. I'VE TALKED ON THIS
FLOOR ABOUT FIRE SINCE THE TIME
I CAME TO THIS LEGISLATURE AND
TRIED TO EDUCATED THAT THERE'S
ONLY ONE WAY. ONE THING THAT WE
CAN ACTUALLY DO TO STOP FIRE
THAT'S TAKE THE FUEL WAY AT
LEAST AROUND OUR COMMUNITIES.
AS I WATCHED MILLIONS OF ACRES
AND HABITAT AND WILDLIFE AND
WATERSHEDS AND CARBON SPEW- OUT
OF. CALIFORNIA AND WE DON'T DO
GOOD POLICY SO I'M JUST BAKING.
TO DO THE RIGHT THING. TRY TO
GO BACK TO MY COMMUNITIES AND
THE OTHER SENATORS THAT
REPRESENT THESE COMMUNITIES.
AND SAY. YOU KNOW WHAT WE CAN
GET IT DONE. THE GOVERNOR SAID
WE DID NINETY THOUSAND ACRES
AND WE REALLY ONLY DID NINE.
CAL FIRE SAYING WE DO ALL THESE
ACRES AND THEY DIDN'T REALLY DO
IT THE PRIVATE PEOPLE DID IT
BECAUSE OUR TEACH PEACE. LET'S
DO SOME MAKERS LET'S TREAT IT
WE HAVE THE RESOURCES WE HAVE
THE MONEY WE HAVE THE PEOPLE TO
DO IT AND THEY'RE ALREADY
SHOVEL READYPROJECTS SO.
MANAGER I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
PROCESS BUT I HAVE THESE
MOMENTS AND I WOULD REQUEST
THAT WE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS. AT WHATEVER
WHATEVER THE DELIVERY TIME IS
THANK YOU SENATOR DOLLY THE- IT
IS NOT REALLY APPROPRIATE TO
TAKE AMENDMENTS AT THIS POINT.
BECAUSE THE WAIVERS WE APPROVED
WERE FOR SPECIFIC BILLS IN
SPECIFIC TIME PERIOD AND WE ARE
PAST THAT TIME PERIOD- FIVE.
ONE ONE MOMENT ONE MOMENT- THE-
I APPRECIATE THAT YOU ARE
FRUSTRATED- IN AN- NOT NOT THAT
IT DIMINISHES IT BUT YOU KNOW
YOU HAVE. PRODUCT KEY ISSUES IN
WHAT N. FRUSTRATION ABOUT THE
FINDING IN PAST BUT WHAT I
WANTED TO CLARIFY IS THAT IN
THIS SECTION THAT WE'RE IF IT'S
TO MEAN HAT WE APPROVE IT.
TONIGHT THERE IS FIFTY MILLION
THAT IS GOING TO RECKLESSLY TO
SIERRA NEVADA CONSERVANCY.
ADDITIONALLY THERE IS A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY MILLION FOR FIRE
PREVENTION GRANTS. YOU'RE
CORRECT THAT IT DOES NOT GO IT
IS NOT ALREADY SPECIFIED FOR
WHICH FIRE COUNSELOR FIRE
SAFETY COUNCIL HOWEVER. THEY
ARE ELIGIBLE TO APPLY AND IF
THEY HAVE SHOVEL READY PROJECTS
THEY WILL BE MORE LIKELY TO
RECEIVE THAT MONEY IMMEDIATELY
AND AS YOU POINTED OUT. THERE
WAS A FIRE BREAK THANK GOODNESS
AROUND TAHOE YES IT WOULD BE
OBVIOUSLY. A GREATLY IMPROVED
HAVE FIRE BREAKS AROUND ALL OF
OUR AREAS THAT ARE. IN THREAT
OF WILDFIRE HOWEVER I THINK IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN HARD FOR ALL OF
US TO ANTICIPATE THE BASICALLY
ALMOST EVERYWHERE IN THE STATE.
THE THREAT OF WILDFIRE NOW- SO
IF I MAY YES GO AHEAD SENATOR
GOING. SO WHAT YOU'RE TELLING
ME IS THAT. OVER LABOR DAY
WEEKEND. THESE BILLS WERE
AMENDED ON MONDAY LABOR DAY.
THAT THERE'S NO OPPORTUNITY TO
AMEND THESE BILLS IN A IN A-
BUDGET COMMITTEE THIS IS A
COMMITTEE THIS ISN'T. SO WHY IS
THE PUBLIC THEN GONNA CALL AND
COMMENT ON ANY OF THESE BILLS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE NO INFLUENCE
OVER THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO.
AFFECT THE LEGISLATION I WOULD
SHARE WITH EVERYBODY THAT'S
WATCHING YOU DON'T NEED TO CALL
IN BECAUSE THERE'S NOTHING YOU
CAN DO IF THE IF THE SENATOR
CAN'T. REMEMBER OR HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MEN THAT NOBODY
DOES SENATOR DOLLY WE WILL
ENTERTAIN THE MOTION- AND I
EIGHT. FIVE NOT TRYING TO BE
RUDE HERE BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
JUST POINT OUT THAT. THE- THE
BILLS BEFORE US LAST WEEK TO
NOT ONLY SCHEDULE THIS HEARING
FOR TO ALSO ALLOW US TO AMEND
BILLS WERE OPPOSED BY YOUR
COLLEAGUES ON THE FLOOR
HOWEVER. WE WILL ALLOW YOU TO
MAKE THE MOTION ON THE
AMENDMENTS THAT YOU'VE
DISTRIBUTED. SO YOU WANT TO
MAKE THEM YES I WOULD BE HAPPY
TO MAKE THAT OKAY DO I NEED TO
READ MY MINUTES IS SO YOU DON'T
NEED TO READ THEM THEY ARE IN
WRITING HERE EVERYONE HAS THEM-
SENATORS SENATOR DOLE HE'S
MAKING A MOTION ON THOSE
AMENDMENTS YOU HAVE BEFORE YOU.
AND HE IS CLEARLY ASKING FOR AN
I. VOTE SO. GO AHEAD SEND IF I
MAY THE PUBLIC HAS NO IDEA WHAT
YOU'RE VOTING ON BECAUSE IT'S
JUST IN FRONT OF THE MEMBERS. I
THINK THE PUBLIC HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO KNOW SHOULD HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO KNOW WHAT
WERE EITHER UP OR DOWN
SUMMARIZED CAN YOU BRIEFLY
SUMMARIZE FIVE SURELY CAN'T
THANK YOU. CERTAINLY MY
MEASUREMENTS WOULD ALLOW. FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF FORTUNE FIVE
REJECTION TO ESTABLISH AND
ADMINISTER GRANTS TO
CONSERVANCIES FIRE SAFE
COUNCILS AND COUNTY GOVERNMENTS
AND THAT ARE HAVE SHOVEL READY
PROJECTS WHAT I STATED EARLIER
THAT MEANS. FIRE SAFE COUNCILS-
OUR CD'S. AND IT ALSO HAS IN
THE SECOND PART OF THE
AMENDMENT IT HAS THE
LEGISLATION TO TAKE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO THE
FROM THE GENERAL FUND MONIES
FOR THE WELFARE PREVENTION WE-
RESILIENCE ACTIVITIES SO
BASICALLY WHAT I'M ASKING YOU.
TO DO IS BUY IN AND IT HAS TO
BE DONE BY. DESCENT BY THE END
OF THE YEAR FOR PROJECT
STARTING NEXT YEAR THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. THIRD SO SENATOR
DOLLY IS- ASKING FOR NO VOTE ON
THOSE AMENDMENTS- I WOULD ONLY
AS I PREVIOUSLY POINTED OUT
THAT. THE- THE HIS AMENDMENT IS
ASKING FOR A DIFFERENT AGENCY
TO ADMINISTER WELL TO
ADMINISTER A LARGER PORTION OF
FUNDS IN THIS AND WHAT WORKS
FOR US BUT WE DO HAVE CAL FIRE.
IN THIS BILL THAT WE HAVE
BEFORE US WITH THE ABILITY TO
FIND THEIR SHOVEL READY
PROJECTS WITH THE TWO EXACTLY
THE SAME ENTITIES THAT SENATOR
DOLE A POINTED OUT SO- I WILL
BE VOTING NO ON THOSE
AMENDMENTS. AND WE CARE AND
HAVE A ROLL CALL. THE SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE CAN GO AHEAD. CAN
WE HAVE A- CLARIFICATION
BECAUSE THE AMENDMENTS BEFORE
US ARE TALKING ABOUT- THE
EXISTING UNDER EXISTING LAW-
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
OFFICE. WILL AUTHORIZES FIVE
HUNDRED. MILLION DOLLARS STACK
WAS. APPROPRIATED EARLIER. THE
LANGUAGE IN- AV ONE SEVENTY NOW
MAKES THAT A FULL PART OF THE
BUDGET SO IT'S NOT WE'RE NOT.
TETHERED TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SAYING YES YOU CAN USE
THIS MONEY ALL THAT MONEY'S
THERE SO. PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
IT'S- IT IS NINE HUNDRED EIGHTY
EIGHT IN THE BUDGET RIGHT NOW
NOT DEPENDENT ON ANYTHING FOR
THE PAT AND FINANCE TO DO. I
JUST WANT TO MAKE THAT
CLARIFICATION. RIGHT THANK YOU
FOR THAT. CLARIFICATION- SENDER
WORKOUTS SKI- RIGHT THE SENATOR
NEWMAN AT THANK YOU AND YOUR
DAD I'M NOT SURE IF THIS
PROGRAM WOULD- IS IT POSSIBLE
TO HAVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE COMMENT ON THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS BEFORE YOU GO. THE
FIRM WE CERTAINLY CAN- MISLEAD
YOU WANNA MAKE A COMMENT. YEAH
I THINK GENERALLY SPEAKING IT
IS DIFFICULT TO MAKE A COMMENT
HAVING JUST HEARD THE
AMENDMENTS- AND I CAN CONTRIVE
DEFER TO MY COLLEAGUE SERGIO
FOR ANY PARTICULARS BUT I THINK
AT THIS POINT WE WOULDN'T FEEL-
WE'RE IN A POSITION TO MAKE
THAT COMMENT- THE PROPOSED PLAN
THAT WE HAVE IN OUR BUDGET IS
AGREED UPON PLAN THAT- IS WHAT.
THE PARKS. YES SIR I GOT A PART
OF FINANCE YEAH HE JUST- THE
KIND OF REITERATE MISSED LEAVE
COMMENTS WE DON'T HAVE TO BE
ABOUT IT SO WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY ARE BUT I'D BE JUST BASED
OFF OF- WITHIN OR WITHOUT HE
WAS MENTIONING IT IF IT'S
UNENDING THAT PROVISION OF THE
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION A
CALIBRATION THAT PROVISION IS
NOT REALLY- THAT LITTLE WAY
MORE BECAUSE ALL OF IT'S
APPROPRIATE. TO ALL RIGHT LET'S
THE- LET'S HAVE A VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS- MR STEPPING SHOCK
COULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION TO AMEND. A. B. ONE
SEVENTY SENATORS SCANNER. NO
SKINNER NO NELSON. NIELSEN HI
CAREER. CARRIER ZERO NO.
CORTESE CORTESE KNOW DOLLY ALI
HI THE RAZA. REISER NO AIKMAN.
HEY MAN NO GROWTH. GROVE I COME
LONGER. COME ON OVER NO LEHRER.
MMHM MMHM LAYERED AND. NO
MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE NO MELINDA'S
HI LINDA I MEANT MAN NO NEWMAN.
NUMBER NOT VOTING FOR TO ABOUT.
TROUBLED HI PAM FAN NO STERN.
MY COFFEE MY COFFEE MILK. FIVE
FIVE NOTES ELEVEN. FOR THE
LOTUS EYES FIVE NOTES ELEVEN
AND SO WE WILL CONTINUE OUR
WITH THOSE MOMENTS ARE NOT
APPROVED WE WILL CONTINUE OUR
DISCUSSION OF THE ITEMS IN THE
LIST. SKEWS ME THAT I HAVE
SENATOR CALM WATER FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR DRAWS OR SENATOR RICK
CASKEY SENATOR MEN AND SENATOR
PAM. BUT IF I MISSED YOU JUST
WAVE AT ME AND I WILL ADD YOU
TO LET'S GO AHEAD SENATOR CALM
WATER. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THIS QUESTION IS- I BELIEVE I
HOPE FOR A DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE OR LA- AND IT IS IN
REGARDS TO- THE WILDFIRE
PREVENTION AND RESILIENCY-
FUNDING FOR OUR CONSERVANCY
LANDS I YOU KNOW I JUST WANT TO
SHARE THAT I AND- YOU KNOW
SORELY DISAPPOINTED IN. THE
ALLOCATIONS- ESPECIALLY AS IT
RELATES TO SOUTH LA I AM NOT
TRYING TO POSIT THAT THIS IS AN
EITHER OR THAT ONE COMMUNITY
OVER ANOTHER SHOULD BE
PRIORITIZED BUT I AM ADVOCATING
FOR MORE- ESPECIALLY AS IT
RELATES TO SOUTH LA. IN THE
LAST TWO SURPLUSES- THE BALDWIN
HILLS AREA WAS LEFT OUT
COMPLETELY. WHILE OTHER
COMMUNITIES WITH OPEN FIELDS
WERE GIVEN RESOURCES- SOUTH LA
THE BALDWIN HILLS CONSERVANCY-
IS A FOUR HUNDRED PLUS- SOME
ACREAGE FROM. PARK WITH OTHER
LANDS IT IS AN URBAN POPULATED
AREA- CLOSE TO HOMES BUT ALSO
INCREDIBLY PROXIMATE TO A VERY
ACTIVE OIL FIELD- AND YET
BALDWIN HILLS HAS EITHER
CONSISTENTLY RECEIVED THE
LOWEST OF ALL CONSERVANCY'S OR
WE'VE BEEN LEFT OUT COMPLETELY-
AND LOOKING THROUGH THIS I WAS
SURPRISED THAT- CANINE BLOOD
BANK GOT MORE FUNDING THAN THE
BALDWIN HILLS CONSERVANCY. THEN
A CONSERVANCY FOR SOUTH LA. SO
I'M JUST CURIOUS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ARE WHAT'S THE
REASONING BEHIND LEAVING OUT. A
CONSERVANCY THAT SERVICES ALL
OF SOUTH LOS ANGELES AND HOW
ARE THESE DETERMINATIONS MADE-
WITH REGARDS TO WHICH
CONSERVANCY'S GOT ALLOCATIONS
AND HOW MUCH THEY GOT. THE HIGH
TENSION MASTER JAGGER PART OF
FINANCE I THINK I WOULD KNOW
THAT YOU'RE GENERALLY WE TRY TO
LOOK AT THE THAT KIND OF HIGHLY
HIGHER FIRE RISK AREAS AS ONE
OF THE CRITERIA BY. WHAT THEY
HAD TO REALLY POINT IS ALL THE
CAL FIRE MR GRANTS THOSE ALL
COMMUNITY THAT SO JUST BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT A SPECIFIC ANSWER
IF HE CALLED OUT IT DOESN'T
MEAN THAT WE GENERAL AREAS NOT
GETTING FUNDING. THE GRANTS
ADMINISTERED BY STATES ARE
ACTUALLY GOING OUT TO THESE
COMMUNITIES THAT APPLIED TO THE
FUNDING- WHICH- YOU KNOW WE'RE
DOING AS BEST WE CAN TO TRY TO
EXPEDITE- THROUGH DIFFERENT
PROCESS SEE THAT SO I JUST
GENERALLY YOU KNOW. FOCUSING ON
HIGH RISK AREAS BUT AGAIN
THERE'S OTHER FUNDING IN THIS
PACKAGE THAT THAT ALL OF THE
REGIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THAT HAVE- VIRUS GOODBYE.
SERVICE CENTER FROM ORDER TO
HAVE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS NO I
JUST WANT TO GET CLARITY SO
THERE ARE SOME CONSERVANCIES
THAT ACTUALLY HAVE A DIRECT
APPLICATION AND THEN YOU'RE
SAYING THERE'S ANOTHER POT OF
MONEY THAT PEOPLE JUST HAVE TO
FIGHT FOR. YEAH AND SO THAT'S
FOR SOUTH LA TO FIGHT FOR. TWO
PACKS. THE WHOLE THE WHOLE PART
OF FINDING AND YET TYPICALLY
REPLICATION PROCESS FOR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TO BE ABLE TO APPLY
BUT ONE OF THE STRATEGY THAT WE
ARE PLANNING HEREAS WELL IS
WORKING TO PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
THE LOCALS TO DEVELOP PLANS AND
DEVELOP PROJECTS THAT THEY
COULD GO THROUGH THE PIPELINE-
I'LL BE THAT CAL FIRE MR GRANT
AND THE CONSERVATIVES AND SO-
IT IS- YOU KNOW AN APPLICATION
PROCESS FOR. THOSE OTHER POTS
OF FUNDING. THANK YOU I MEAN
I'M NOT LESS DISAPPOINTED BUT
AT LEAST YOU ANSWERED THE
QUESTION. SENATOR DRAWS- THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- I WANT TO
COMMENT ON A B. ONE FIFTY FIVE
AND A B. ONE SIXTY TWO. IS
THAT. CERTAIN OKAY THANK YOU-
AND BOTH OF THEM HAVE TO DO
WITH- ECONOMIC. IMPACTS OF. OF
OUR RESOURCES AND PROGRAMS ON
A. B. ONE FIFTY FIVE. FROM. YOU
KNOW AS AS WE HAVE THE NEED FOR
PROJECTS THAT RESPOND TO OUR
OUR CLIMATE NEEDS AS THOSE- AS
THAT INCREASES. IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT SO DO THE NUMBER OF
WORKERS NEEDED TO TAKE ON-
THOSE PROJECTS- WHEN WE ADDRESS
ENVIRONMENTAL. ISSUES AND
ECONOMIC ECONOMIC IMPACT
REQUIRED THAT THE STATE HAS TO
ALIGN THE CLIMATE AND THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT GOALS WE
NEED TO INVEST IN THE PEOPLE
AND THE PROGRAMS. TO ALLEVIATE
THOSE IMPACTS BUT ALSO IN A
MORE POSITIVE WAY BENEFIT FROM
THIS ECONOMY THIS GREEN ECONOMY
THAT WE'RE INVESTING IN- SO WHY
DO WE NEED. CONSERVATION WORK
FORCE DEVELOPMENT IN A VERY
EXPLICIT WAY NOT THAT MAYBE
IT'LL HAPPEN WHO KNOWS WHICH
ORGANIZATIONS. BUT RIGHT NOW WE
DON'T HAVE AN EFFECTIVE
WORKFORCE PIPELINE TO TRAIN
YOUNG ADULTS. FOR STATE OR
LOCAL PARKS DEPARTMENTS- AND
OTHER CAREERS IN THE NATURAL
RESOURCES FIELD- AND I THINK
THAT IF WE'RE GOING TO ACHIEVE
THE STATES OUR CLIMATE GOALS
WHICH WERE ALL IN SUPPORT OF-
THAT MEANS THAT WE NEED TO HAVE
AN EXPANDED AND A SKILLED
WORKFORCE. READY ARM AND THAT
MEANS WE HAVE TO HAVE THE
EDUCATION THE TRAINING THE
CERTIFICATIONS THAT WE NEED. TO
BUILD THESE CLIMATE CAREERS.
AND THESE CONSERVATION WORK
FORCE PROGRAMS ARE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ALIGN OUR
ECONOMIC GOALS AND OUR CLIMATE
GOALS THE WORKING POOR THE USE
OF- COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
LEFT OUT OF A LOT OF OTHER
CAREERS. WHAT DO THEY SEE IN
THEIR FUTURE HOW ARE THEY GOING
TO GET PREPARED FOR THAT FUTURE
OR IS THAT SOMETHING THAT JUST
TOTALLY OUT OF OUT OF REACH FOR
THEM SO. I JUST WANT TO COMMENT
IT'S NOT A SPECIFIC- BUT- IT'S
NOT A SPECIFIC ASK RIGHT NOW
BUT IT SEEMS TO ME THAT KIND OF
INFORMATION- ALWAYS GETS LEFT
OUT AND- I DON'T THINK THAT
WERE- WE'RE REALLY ADDRESSING A
NEW GREEN ECONOMY AND- ALL THE
NEEDS THAT WE HAVE FOR CLIMATE
MITIGATION IF. WE'RE NOT
ADDRESSING- THE MEN AND WOMEN
WE'RE GOING TO HELP US REACH
THOSE CLIMATE GOALS- ON AB ONE
SIXTY TWO. I'M VERY EXCITED.
THAT THIS INCLUDES HIGHROAD
LANGUAGE AND HIGH ROAD
LANGUAGES SOMETHING THAT- YOU
KNOW OF ADDRESSES OF METRICS ON
EQUITY. ON JOB QUALITY ON
SUSTAINABILITY WAGE INCREASES
ALL THE JOB CREATION. ALL OF
THAT NEEDS TO BE INCLUDED AND
I'M I'M GLAD WE'RE GOING TO GET
A REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE BOB
THIS. BUT IT SEEMS TO ME WE
NEED TO SEE THIS AND ALL THE
SPENDING ON THE GROUND PROGRAMS
IF WE'RE REALLY GOING TO BUILD
A WORKER CENTERED ON
SUSTAINABLE ECONOMY ALL FOR
EVERYONE. WE'RE SUPPOSED TO AND
WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF
SPENDING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
AN ELECTRIC VEHICLE
ELECTRIFICATION AND ALSO ON
INFRASTRUCTURE- ODD DOLLARS-
ARE WE PAYING ATTENTION TO THE
JOBS ARE BEING CREATED ARE WE
REALLY CREATING THOSE JOBS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA WELL WE ALONE
WITH THE MONEY THAT WE'RE GOING
TO INVEST- WE COULD CREATE AND
SUSTAIN OVER EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
JOBS JUST ON THE ISSUE OF
TRANSPORTATION SO. I JUST- YOU
KNOW IT INVEST IN OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE WE HAD A REPORT
THAT SAID- CLOSE TO THE
LEGISLATURE PUTTING CALIFORNIA
ON THE HIGH ROAD A JOBS AND
CLIMATE ACTION PLAN FOR TWENTY
THIRTY IT EMPHASIZED THAT
INVESTMENTS IN INFRASTRUCTURE
ALONE WILL NOT CREATE A HIGH
QUALITY JOBS WE HAVE TO HAVE
BOTH THE SUPPLY AND THE DEMAND
SIDE- TO CREATE HIGH ROAD
FAMILY SUSPECT SUSTAINING JOBS
FOR OUR FUTURE- SO I JUST WANT
TO MAKE THOSE COMMENTS. I HOPE
THAT THE YOU KNOW AS WE GET
READY I'M SURE OF SOON TO START
TALKING ABOUT NEXT YEAR'S
BUDGET THAT WE ARE MUCH MORE
EXPLICIT ON THESE TWO ISSUES
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK
YOU SENATOR DRAWS OUR SENATOR
WHITE COW SKI. THE CITY. LET'S
START WITH THE AD PACKAGE- FROM
THE SENATE PROPOSAL INCLUDED
TWENTY MILLION FOR INVASIVE
SPECIES COUNCIL AND TWENTY
MILLION FOR UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA RESEARCH REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GAS IMPACTS ON
AGRICULTURE. FINANCES COME BACK
WITH FIVE MILLION ON EACH IS IT
NOT IMPORTANT AT THE UNIVERSITY.
STATE REDUCING GREENHOUSE GASES
OR THAT INVASIVE SPECIES WITH
CLIMATE CHANGE IS NOT A PROBLEM
FOR- DEPARTMENT FINANCE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR QUESTIONS ARE
REALLY COSTLY AND AS NOTED-
EARLIER THIS- WHAT THE
NEGOTIATION AND THERE WERE A
LOT OF THINGS THAT WERE- IND
THAT MANY DIFFERENT THINGS IN
THE ACT PACKAGE- AND THAT.
LEAVE THIS- A TEN MILLION
DOLLAR FUNDING OVER MULTIPLE
OVER TWO YEARS IN IN IN
PARTICULAR BUT I WILL TRY TO
SCRATCH YOU KNOW FOR MORE
DETAILS TO SIR JACK ARE PERHAPS
I COULD REFRESH YOUR MEMORY IN
IN MAY WHEN THE GOVERNOR SENT
US THE MAY REVISE. HE HAD ONE
POINT SIX NINE FOUR BILLION FOR
CLIMATE RESILIENCY. THE SENATE
TOOK AN ACTION TO RAISE THAT TO
THREE. OF THREE BILLION SIX
HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE FIVE AND
NOW IT'S BECOME THREE THOUSAND
SIX HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE SO
WELL THERE'S A LOT OF CREDIT
BEING TAKEN AROUND TOWN FOR
REACHING THE RESILIENCY PACKAGE
I THINK IT WAS THIS BODY TO
TOOK THE ACTION THIS COMMITTEE.
THAT THAT ACTUALLY RAISE THAT
SO MY QUESTION WAS YOU SET OUT
YOUR PRIORITIES WE SET OUT OUR
PRIORITIES AND AT LEAST ON
INVASIVE SPECIES N. N. REDUCING
CHANGE GREENHOUSE GAS RESEARCH
ON AGRICULTURE AND FOOD
PRODUCTION. THEY- THEY DON'T.
THEY HAVE BEEN MADE TO THE MARK
I GUESS THE NEXT QUESTION ON
THE OF AGRICULTURE'S WE HAD
NINETY MILLION FOR THE
DEPARTMENT CONSERVATION. OF FOR
THE FARMLAND PROTECTION PROGRAM
WHICH WE BELIEVE IN THE SENATE.
THAT PROTECTING FARMLAND IS
IMPORTANT THAT BEEN. CAN YOU.
IT TO THE COMMITTEE WILL NOT
MILLION WAS REMOVE BY FIVE.
AGAIN HAS NOT REGISTERED YOUR
REGULAR CUSTOMER DETAILS. IF
THEIR GENERAL PART OF FINANCE I
MEAN JUST TO REITERATE NEWS
LEAVE A COMMENT THOSE ARE JUST
PART OF A COMPROMISE OF
BALANCING THAT MEETS YOUR
PRIORITIES OF- BOTH THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION AND SO AS PART
OF THAT- THIS- PACKAGE THAT
BEFORE YOU IS THE COMP RIGHT
BACK. C. SURGERY I'M CURIOUS
ABOUT THAT BECAUSE BECAUSE THEY
SAID THE GOVERNOR WANTED ONE
POINT SIX NINE BILLION I MAY
AND THE SENATE ONE OF THREE
POINT SIX SO WE'VE- ADDED WE'RE
IN WE ARE NOW AT THREE POINT
SIX SEVEN FIVE BUT AS I GO
THROUGH THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REQUEST. TWENTY FIVE MILLION
FOR CLIMATE ADAPTATION GRANTS
HE GOT IT TWENTY FOR REGIONAL
CLIMATE. CREPITUS
COLLABORATIVE'S HE GOT IT-
WHERE'S THE OTHER THING. I KNOW
TO MANY FIRE. EXCUSE ME. MY
CONCERN IS THAT THE SENATE
PRIORITIES THAT WERE LAID OUT
IN MAY. DIDN'T RECEIVE ANYTHING.
SO THAT'S THE ACT PACKAGE WHICH
I THINK THE GOVERNOR GOT
EVERYTHING THAT HE WANTED BUT
LET'S LET'S LET'S MOVE TO THE
CLIMATE RESILIENCY PACKAGE
BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S ONE OF
THE GREATEST CONCERN THE SENATE
LAID OUT A PRIORITY FOR AS
WE'VE HEARD MY- COLLEAGUE MS
COM LOCKER TALK ABOUT STATE
CONSERVANCY PROGRAMS IN THIS
MISTER DOLLIES FAILED-
AMENDMENT IS OTHER RESILIENCY
PROGRAMS OUTSIDE THE DEPARTMENT
OF RESOURCES WE ALLOCATED SIX
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR CLIMATE RESILIENCY
PROGRAM SO THIS IS NOT ONLY
FIRE PROGRAMS BUT WATER
PROGRAMS HIGH ALPINE PROGRAMS
IN. WE GOT SIXTY MILLION. THIS
YEAR PLUS MAYBE A PROMISE THAT
MAYBE YOU'LL GIVE US SOME MORE
NEXT YEAR- AND I'M WONDERING.
THAT HE'S BEEN IN THE PUBLIC
REALM SINCE MAY MAY JUNE JULY
AUGUST SEPTEMBER YET. YOU HAVE
CHOSEN TO COME UP WITH. THREE
TWO HUNDRED MILLION FOR ITS
COMMUNITY RESILIENCY CENTERS
AND THREE HUNDRED MILLION FOR
EXTREME HEAT- SECTORS WHERE DID
THAT COME FROM WORD TO WORD
THAT WAS NOT PART OF THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE WAS NOT
PART OF ME- WORKED AT THE
SENATE DID WITH THOSE NUMBERS
COME INSTEAD OF THE CONSERVANCY
PURPOSES WHICH WE HAVE. HEARD
FROM SYDNEY MANY SENATORS ARE
BEING OVER SUBSCRIBED IN.
WANTING HAVING SHOVEL READY
PROJECTS. YES I SPEAK A LITTLE
BIT TO THE CONCERN OF THE
FUNDING SO THERE'S SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE CLAMP
PACKAGING TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
I WILL KNOW THAT IN THE OUT
YEARS THERE'S ACTUALLY ALSO
FINDING THAT COUNTRIES ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR AND THERE'S
ACTUALLY A MINIMUM OF SIXTY
MILLION PER YEAR AND THOSE
BARRIERS. THAT WE INCLUDED IN
THE TRAILER BILL AS PART OF
SATISFIED AND THAT TO A MINIMUM
AMOUNT AND SO FOR EXAMPLE IF
YOU LOOK AT THE- THAT MOSTLY
BENEFIT NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS
IT IS ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED AND
SIXTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AT
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR. AND A
TRAILER BILL EXPLICITLY FIVE
CONSERVANCY- ELIGIBLE AND
ACTUALLY PROVIDE THE MINIMUM
LEVEL THE CONSERVATIVES FILLER
PROSELYTIZING FOR AROUND WHERE
YOU KNOW THAT THEY COULD- APPLY
WITH SPECIFICALLY THAT POT OF
FUNDING IS WHERE YOU KNOW. IN
THE NEXT COUPLE YEARS THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL WORK WITH
THE LEGISLATURE EXACTLY PROGRAM
THOSE DOLLARS ACCORDING TO HOW
THE KIND OF TRAILER WILL
OUTLINE THE TYPICAL THE
ELIGIBLE USES WHICH AGAIN
INCLUDES CONSERVANCY. ON OTHER
CONCERT AT THE JUST THAT
CLARIFY. ON THE EXTREME HEAT SO
PART OF WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION
LOOK BAD IS LOOKING AT HOW TO
ADDRESS OUR VARIOUS CLIMATE
RISKS AND EXTREME BEING EXTREME
HEAT BEING- THE EMERGING AND
IMMEDIATE CLIMATE RISK THE
MINISTRATIONS ACTUALLY WORKING
ON AN EXTREME HEAT FRAMEWORK
THAT'S GOING TO BE RELEASED
LATER THIS YEAR SO AS PART OF
THAT THAT THERE BE DIFFERENT
STRATEGY THAN. PROGRAMS THAT
WOULD BE DEVELOPED WHAT WE
WOULD HAVE HAD TO COME BACK TO
THE LEGISLATURE- WITH- OUR
PROPOSAL FOR THE VARIOUS
PROGRAMS TO THEN BE PART OF
THAT DISCUSSION DURING THE
BUDGET PROCESS YEAH BECAUSE IT
YOU KNOW WE HAVEN'T HAD
HEARINGS ON THAT AND IT SEEMS
LIKE YOU'RE TREATING THE
CONSEQUENCE YOU KNOW WE KNOW
WHEN WE HAVE WHEN THE CLIMATE
WILL CHANGE THERE WILL BE
CONSEQUENCES WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO HERE. IS ANTICIPATE THE
CAUSATION THE SAY OKAY THERE'S
TOO MUCH FUEL IN THE FOREST WE
NEED TO REMOVE IT NOT WHEN. THE
FORCES BURNING UP WHAT WE HAD
TO ADD AFTER WE DO HAVE SOME MY-
FOR TREE PLANTING. LET'S GET TO
THE SEVEN HUNDRED C. EIGHT THAT
IS THE MALL BAND- FLOOD IT
SEEMS LIKE WE CONFLATED A BUNCH
OF- SEGMENTS AND IN THERE AND
I'VE BEEN TRYING TO WORK
THROUGH THE LEGEND OF THE BILL
BUT I HAVEN'T ACTUALLY GOTTEN
TO HELL THAT'S BREAK. BROKEN
OUT BUT DAD. I DON'T YOU'RE
SAYING THAT THAT'S WHAT MONEY
FOR CONSERVANCY'S OR SOME OF
THE WORK THAT MAY HAVE BEEN
DONE FOR CLIMATE RESILIENCY
PROJECTS. YOU'RE GOING TO WORK
OUT. SO THERE'S TRAIL ROLE
LANGUAGE- AND- ONE FIFTY FIVE
EXACTLY DETAILS- THIS POT OF
FUNDING AND THAT THE ALLIES
WILL USE THAT AND SO-
ENERGETICALLY DETAILS
CONSERVANCY HAT HAVE A MINIMUM
AMOUNT THAT GOES THROUGH PEOPLE
GET. IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
AT TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR SO
IT JUST LOOK AT THE CONTEXT ON
ON THAT KIND OF THE CONCEPT OF
THE SATISFIED- WEEKNIGHT IF
THERE'S YOU KNOW MUTUAL SHARED
PRIORITIES- WITH A DIFFERENT
NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS A THIRTY
BY THIRTY GOALS. THE
RESTORATION IS ACTUALLY GONNA
BE COMING OUT WITH A COUPLE
DIFFERENT STRATEGIES OVER THE
COURSE OF THE NEXT SEVERAL
MONTHS- RELATED TO THIRTY BY
THIRTY- WHICH- THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER LAST YEAR ADDED A LOT TO
A BILL PASSED. THAT CAMPAIGN IF
I'D BE A VISUAL COMPOSER WITH A
STRATEGY ON HOW TO ADDRESS A
THIRTY BY THIRTY GOALS AND THEN
THERE'S ALSO GOING TO BE AN
UPDATED NATIONAL WORKING LAND
CLIMATE SMART STRATEGY. AS TO
WHAT WE WANT IF WE WANT TO BE
ARE YOUR FUNDING TO BE INFORMED
BY THOSE STRATEGIES WHERE WE
HAVE TO HAVE TO COME BACK TO
THE LEGISLATURE TO PRESENT.
HERE'S A STRATEGY THAT HERE'S
THE PROPOSED PROGRAM THAT WE
WANT TO ADDRESS THE VARIOUS
TYPES OF GOALS AND EFFORTS BUT
AGAIN THAT WOULD GO THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS THOSE
FUTURE YEARS. WELL WE ACCESS
THE CIVICALLY INCLUDED
CONSERVANCIES WITHIN THE
TRAINER BILL LANGUAGE IT'LL BE
KNOWLEDGE THAT THAT IS A TOP
PRIORITY OF THE SENATE AND AS
LONG AS- AND MANY OTHER
NUMBERS. YEAH I DON'T I DON'T
THINK I'M EXPRESSING MYSELF IN
THE RIGHT FORM IT WAS OUR IDEA
TO HAVE THE CLIMATE RESILIENCY
B. AT THREE POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLAR PACKAGE NOT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S YOU WANT ONE
POINT SIX WERE THREE POINT SIX.
SO IT'S GREAT THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO COME BACK TO US. AND MAYBE
INCLUDE SOME OF OUR CONSERVANCY
PROJECTS THAT THE GROUP
REPUBLICAN SIDE IN EVERY MEMBER
HERE HAS BEEN SAYING WE'RE
READY TO BUILD WE WANT TO
REMOVE SOME. FUEL WE WANNA FIX
UP OUR RIVERS WHO WANTED-
REPAIR OUR WHAT. I GUESS. LET'S
SEE. D. YOU HAVE REGIONAL
CLIMATE RESPONSE PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS. WHERE
DID THAT COME FROM BECAUSE
THAT'S NOT IN THE MAY BUDGET
IT'S NOT IN ANYTHING THAT WE
DID IN THE SENATE. SEPT TWO IN
THIS BUDGET. YOU'VE GOT YEAH I
MEAN YOU'VE GOT THE YOU'VE GOT
THE ENTIRE AMOUNT THAT THE
GOVERNOR WANTED FOR- T. CC'S
TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES HOLE FOR FOUR
HUNDRED TWENTY BUT THIS IS TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY ON TOP OF THAT.
AND AGAIN. IT'S A CAUSATION OR
IS IT THE CONSEQUENCES.
KERLIKOWSKE DISS- ERIC LEAVE
THE DEPARTMENT OF. ON THIS DATE
DOES THAT SO IT'S A THREE WAY
NEGOTIATION IT WAS A DEAL
BETWEEN THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
SENATE AND THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THE PLAN FOR YOU IS THE
PREDEFINED L. E. YOU. AGAIN YOU
FUNDED EVERYTHING THAT THE
GOVERNOR WANTED THE FOOT THE
TCC. URBAN GREENING CENTERS
EVERYTHING IS YOUR NUMBER AND
THEN YOU ADD THIS NEW STUFF IN.
HI I MEAN YOU SAY IT'S A THREE
WAY DEAL. IT'S NOT THIS IS NOT
THE SUBJECT WASN'T EVEN ON ON%
OUR PROPOSAL I MEAN I GET A
THREE WAY DEAL WHERE YOU SAY
YOU WANT FIVE HUNDRED WE GOING
THREE HUNDRED YOU GET FOUR
HUNDRED. THAT I DON'T SEE ANY
OF THAT WE HAVE. COASTAL
PROTECTION FOR PROJECTS IN THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY ZERO WETLAND
RESTORATION FOR THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY ZERO COASTAL
PROTECTION FOR PROJECTS IN
SANTA. ANA RIVER CONSERVANCY
FORTY MILLION ZERO KELP
RESTORATION FOR FISHERIES ZERO.
BUT THE STATE PARKS GOT THEIR
TWELVE MILLION FOR SEA LEVEL
RISE BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT THE
GOVERNOR WANTED. SENATOR
MURKOWSKI OF GOD A NUMBER OF
OTHER MEMBERS ON MY LIST. WELL
I THERE'S FRUSTRATION THOSE
BEEN EXPRESSED- FROM THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE AISLE FROM OTHER
MEMBERS ABOUT THE INTEGRITY OF
THE CLIMATE RESILIENCE WE'RE-
WE'RE- TRYING TO EXPRESS THE
DESIRE TO ACTUALLY HAVE.
PROJECTS THAT REDUCE THE CAUSES
OF CLIMATE NOT TO REACT TO HOW
WE'RE GOING TO REBUILD OUR
CITIES AFTER THE AFTER THEY'VE
BEEN REMOVED AND IT'S JUST-
ANAHEIM. SMALL I'LL LEAVE IT AT
THAT MISS MADAM CHAIR IT'S-
IT'S THOSE. ZACKS EXASPERATING
TO BE ABLE AT THE LABOR DAY
WEEKEND AND TRYING TO GO
THROUGH- THREE THOUSAND PAGES
HERE FOR THE PUBLIC TO SEE TO
BE THERE THEIR GUARD AGAIN SOME
PEOPLE ARE SAYING WHAT ARE YOU
DOING FOR OUR CLIMATE. AND WHAT
YOU DO FOR WILDFIRES AND IT
SEEMS LIKE WE'RE YOU KNOW ITS-
IT'S AN INSPIRATIONAL IT'S NOT
BOLD IT'S NOT OTHER RHETORIC
THAT WE'VE HEARD I APOLOGIZE
FOR CARRYING ON- HELLO- NOT TO
MINIMIZE YOU HAVE EXPRESSED HER
FRUSTRATION HOWEVER WHAT I WANT
TO REMIND MEMBERS. IS THAT. WE
ON THIS PACKAGE WHICH YOU MOST
OF YOUR MEN BRING ENOUGH
RESOURCES. EXCEPT FOR THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
IN ALMOST EVERY CASE WE ARE
USING GENERAL FUND DOLLARS WE
HAVE NEVER BEEN IN A
CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE WE HAD
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS TO BE ABLE
TO ALLOCATE IN THIS WAY. SO OF
COURSE AT THE POINT WHERE WE DO
FORTUNATELY BECAUSE OF HIGHER
REVENUES THAN ALL OF US FEEL
VERY STRNGLY ABOUT HOW TO
ALLOCATE THEM AND WE'RE NOT
ALWAYS GOING TO GET THE MALACHY
DID THE WAY. THAT WE AND I
DON'T MEAN TO INDICATE THAT
THIS IS JUST ONE INDIVIDUAL
BUT- IT'S- THE YOU KNOW THESE
THINGS ARE NEGOTIATED AND- IT
IS QUITE SIGNIFICANT AS YOU
POINTED OUT CENTER WACO SKI
THAT WE HAVE THREE POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLARS HERE FOR
CLIMATE RESILIENCY. AND I'M
CONFIDENT THAT WE HAVE ANOTHER
BITE AT THE APPLE TO NEGOTIATE
SOME OTHER DETAILS IN IT. AND
THAT AS WE KNOW GIVEN THAT IT
IS ALREADY- MIDDLE AUGUST THAT-
EVEN IF WE HAD APPROPRIATED IN
VARIOUS OF THE PACKAGES MORE
FOR SAY THIS FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN HARD. TO EXPENDITURES DUE
TO THE FACT THAT WE ARE THAT WE
WEREN'T EXPECTING WE DON'T HAVE
EVERYTHING IN PLACE TO SPEND
LARGE AMOUNTS OF MONEY SO I
THINK THIS IS A- REALLY GOOD
TIME FOR US TO BE. BRITAIN
ROLLING UP OUR SLEEVES AND
GETTING INTO MORE DETAIL SO
THAT WE CAN. REALLY VISIT AND
ALSO OBVIOUSLY IN OUR
APPROPRIATIONS FOR THE
FOLLOWING YEAR. BUT I AM VERY
VERY IMPRESSED AND I THINK WE
SHOULD ALL BE THAT WE ARE
DIRECTING THIS LEVEL OF
INVESTMENT TOWARDS WILDFIRE
TOWARDS DROUGHT. TOWARDS
CLIMATE RESILIENCY SO AGAIN I
HAVE THERE'S A NUMBER OF
FRUSTRATIONS IN. I GOT A
SERVICE MANAGER PLEASE I DO
WHAT I WANT FOR US BUT I THINK
WE ALSO DO I DON'T WANT TO AND
IT IS A FUNNY ANALOGY TO MAKE
EITHER ONE OF THEM IS THE
FORESIGHT WHICH I DO HAVE. WE
MADE A BUDGET DEAL THAT SAID WE
WERE GOING TO SPEND FOUR
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
THIS BUDGET YEAR ON CLIMATE
RESILIENCE AND THAT WAS AGAINST
THE SENATE RECOMMENDATION THAT
WE TAKE THE THREE POINT SIX
CENTS PER ITEM OFF OVER THREE
YEARS. THE MEASURE IN FRONT OF
US IS ONLY SPENDING THREE
POINT. THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
NINE. MILL SO WHERE DID THE
OTHER SEVENTY ONE MILLION GO
THAT DAY WE ALREADY GOT CHOPPED
DOWN BUT NOW WE GOT CHOPPED
DOWN ANOTHER SEVENTY ONE
MILLION WERE. THE FIRE
PREVENTION OR ALL THESE OTHER
PROGRAMS CLIMATE YOU KNOW SAN
FRANCISCO BAY RESTORATION WHILE
REVENUES WILLING WE'LL BE ABLE
TO REVISIT. AND APOLOGIES BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO CALL ON THE OTHER
SENATORS WHO I HAVE ON THE LIST-
HE HAD OTHER NAMES I HAVE HERE
ARE SENATOR MENTIONED OR PAN
SENATOR NELSON SENATOR DOLLY.
AM I MISSING SOMEONE SENATOR
MCGUIRE. APOLOGIES WHO DID I
MISS. OKAY SENATOR MAN GO AHEAD-
S. CAN BE A TOUGH ACT TO FOLLOW
I JUST HAD ONE VERY NARROW
QUESTION- IS SO GOING TO THE
EDUCATION INDEPENDENT STUDY
ISSUE- I WASN'T QUITE CLEAR ON
SORT OF- HOW SOME OF THE
DIFFERENT MOVING PARTS-
INTERACTED AND SO- I UNDERSTAND
THAT- THE ELEAZAR MAY OBTAIN
SIGNED INDEPENDENT STUDY
MASTERS AGREEMENTS AFTER.%
THIRTY DAYS BYE THEY WILL GET
APPORTIONMENT. AND THE ADA
FUNDING ISSUE KIND OF GETS
TAKEN OFF THE TABLE THIS IS AN
ISSUE IS BROUGHT TO MY
ATTENTION I LOVE MY LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS- AND I GUESS
THAT COME WITH THE MAIN THING
THAT THE STREET ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT STRUCK ME I THINK
THIS. CASE CAROLINA THEIR
CONCERNS AROUND. THE USE OF
INDEPENDENT STUDY TO DEAL WITH
COVERT NINETEEN QUARANTINES
BUT- ONE THING THAT THEY AND
NUMBER OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS
POINTED OUT TO ME IS THAT. IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT TO GET THE
STUDENTS TO ACTUALLY COMPLETE
THEIR INDEPENDENT STUDY PACKETS
WHEN THERE ARE IN QUARANTINE.
AND THEY WERE CONCERNED THAT
THE- WHEN THESE WERE NOT
COMPLETED THAT THEY MIGHT BE
PENALIZED AND I WASN'T QUITE
CLEAR- FROM THAT. FROM THE GET
A- MATERIALS THAT WE RECEIVED
WHETHER AT LEAST WE'LL GET
FUNDING WENT REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER STUDENTS TO COMPLETE
THOSE AND IT HAS THE FACTS.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. I DON'T
KNOW MAN I'LL TAKE MY QUESTION
TO JUST. THANK YOU TESCO HOMES
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO THE
WAY THAT INDEPENDENT STUDY AN
EIGHTY EIGHTY FOR PURPOSES OF
APPORTIONMENT IS EARNED-
PURSUANT TO EXISTING LAW THAT
EXISTED PRIOR TO COPE. IS THAT
STUDENTS COMPLETE OUR WORK
PRODUCT ASSIGNED TO THEM BY
THEIR TEACHER- AND THIS COULD
CONSIST OF MANY DIFFERENT
THINGS BUT ESSENTIALLY THERE
HAS TO BE SOME SORT OF TANGIBLE
WORK PODUCT THAT COMES FROM
IT- AND THE TEACHER ASSIGNED A
TIME VALUE TO THAT WORK
PRODUCT- THAT IS THEN USED
WHEN- AUDITORS LOOK AT. THE I.
S. PROGRAM IF IT'S A PROGRAM-
IS AN AUDITED- FOR PURPOSES OF
DETERMINING HOW MUCH A PERSON
AN EIGHTY PERSON IN THIS
EARNED. SO THAT'S KIND OF A
LONG ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION
THE SHORT ANSWER TO YOUR
QUESTION IS- TO THE EXTENT THAT
L. E. A. IS CHOOSING TO USE
PACKETS AS THE METHOD FOR-
EXCITING TIME VALUE TO
ASSIGNMENTS YES THOSE WOULD
NEED TO BE COMPLETED IN ORDER
FOR. THEIR PORTION TO BE EARNED
THAT'S HOW THE TIME IS-
CALCULATED THE TIME VALUE OF
AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE IS
CALCULATED FOR PURPOSES OF
RUNNING A PORTION INDEPENDENT
STUDY HOWEVER I WOULD NOTE THAT
THAT IS THE MORE TRADITIONAL
INDEPENDENT STUDY. THERE'S ALSO.
COURSE BASED INDEPENDENT STUDY.
HI IS IT TO MODEL- IS OF COURSE.
MODEL SO- A SCHOOL WOULD AND
PUT TOGETHER OF COURSE- AND GET
IT APPROVED AS THE COURSE BASED
I. S. BETTER OFF COURSE WITH
INDEPENDENT STUDY THAT THEY'RE
OFFERING. AND STUDENTS WOULD
JUST GET- THEY WOULD EARN A
PORTION OR THEY'RE ONLY EIGHT
BASED ON THEIR THE PERCENTAGE
OF COMPLETION OF THE COURSE AND
THAT DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN.
THE WORK PRODUCT AND THAT THAT
IS THE EQUIVALENT INDEPENDENT
STUDY. HOPEFULLY HOPEFULLY. I
ANSWER THAT QUESTION FOR YOU.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT- I'M
SENATOR PANTS. THANK YOU A MAN
BUT IF BUDGET CHAIR- TO VIC.
COMMENT AND THEN A QUESTION- SO
FIRST OF ALL I'D THE COMMENT
IS- IS- THE- CITY CENTER
REPRESENTING THE SIXTH DISTRICT
ACTUALLY- MY DISTRICT IS ONE OF
THE MAJOR HUBS FOR- ACTUALLY
AFGHAN REFUGEES IN THE WHOLE
COUNTRY AND- SO I DID WANT TO
EXPRESS MY- GRATITUDE AND
APPRECIATION TO THE GOVERNOR
AND- ADMINISTRATION. TO INCLUDE
THE SIXTEEN POINT SEVEN MILLION
AND GENERAL FUND TO HELP
SUPPORT. AFGHAN CITIZENS
DIRECTLY FROM AFGHANISTAN AND
SO THAT WE CAN PROVIDE THEM THE
SUPPORT AND HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AS THEY- COME TO OUR STATE. MY
QUESTION ACTUALLY IS PERTAINS
TO THE FUNDING TO- FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH SO I APPRECIATE IN
EIGHTY ONE SEVENTY- THERE'S AN
ALLOCATION OF APPROXIMATELY
HALF A BILLION DOLLARS- TO THE
PART OF PUBLIC HEALTH- FROM THE
CDC FOR THROUGH THIS GRANT AS
WELL AS- YOU KNOW THERE'S NO
FUNDS FOR. THE RE OPENING
SCHOOLS AND THEN FINALLY-
NINETEEN POINT THREE MILLION.
THE DPH PURSUANT TO FEDERAL
HEALTH DISPARITIES GRANT AWARD-
SO. APPRECIATE THIS FEDERAL
FUNDING GOING TO THE- THE PART
OF PUBLIC. HEALTH BUT I GUESS.
I HAD SOME. ABOUT MORE
SPECIFICS AND I GUESS THE- WELL
IT DOWN TO. FIRST OF ALL- IS
ANY OF THAT POOR AND ANY
PORTION OF THAT MONEY
PARTICULARLY- THE HALF A
BILLION- FROM CDC AND THE
NINETEEN POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLAR DAYS. ALL GOING TO THE
STATE THE PROBABLY COULTER SOME
OF THAT'S BEING THEN. RE
GRANTED BY THE C. PH TO LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS. AND SECOND
OF ALL I APPRECIATE THAT WE ARE
STILL IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
COVETED PANDEMIC AND WELL WE
NOW HAVE VACCINES FREELY
AVAILABLE TO MANY. CALIFORNIANS
THERE ARE STILL- YOU KNOW.
ACTUALLY THE CASE NUMBER. OF
HOSPITALIZATIONS IN THE COUNTRY
IS. ABOVE WHAT WAS LAST YEAR
EVEN HERE IN CALIFORNIA THAT'S
THE CASE SO THEY'RE NOT AS BAD
AS MANY OTHER STATES- WHAT.
PORTION IN TERMS OF THIS FUNNY
ASIDE FROM DIRECT SERVICES FOUR
COVE IT. WHAT PORTION OF THIS
MONEY WILL BE USED TO ACTUALLY
ENHANCE OUR UBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH INCLUDES.
IN INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
INVESTMENTS SO WE HAVE BAITED
BETTER DATA TRANSFER- STAFFING
AND LABORATORY CAPACITY BECAUSE
AGAIN BECAUSE IT'S NOT GOING
AWAY ANYTIME SOON UNFORTUNATELY
AS MUCH AS WE WERE HOPING. THAT
BY THIS FALL WE DOUBT BE OUT OF
THE WOODS WE'RE CLEARLY NOT
THERE AND- I DON'T ANTICIPATE
THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN- BEFORE
THE END OF THIS COMING BUDGET
YEAR EITHER SO HE'S CAN. CAN
YOU PLEASE TELL ME IN MORE
SPECIFIC DETAILS IN TERMS OF.
THESE FUNDS PROPORTIONS GONNA
GO ON TO LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND WHAT PORTION IS
GOING TO BE INVESTED BEYOND
DIRECT SERVICES. INTO PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE. CENTER
CAN ALSO I PLACE YOU OVER TO
ONE MY COLLEAGUE IN OUR HEALTH
UNIT. HI THIS IS- ADAM DORSEY
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO- IT'S-
SLIGHTLY COMPLICATED BECAUSE
THERE'S A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
GRANTS AND EACH OF THEM HAVE
SORT OF A HISTORICALLY
DIFFERENT- ALLOCATION BUT- FOR
THE MOST PART THE FEDERAL
GRANTS FROM THE CDC MOSTLY GO
TO. LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS-
THE MOST RECENT- CDC GRANT- THE
ABOUT A BILLION DOLLARS I
BELIEVE WAS WHAT IS ALLOCATED
TO LOCAL- HEALTH JURISDICTIONS.
AND I THINK THAT'S PRETTY
TYPICAL IN TERMS OF A
PERCENTAGE OF TOTAL- MOST OF
THESE GRANTS DO TYPICALLY GET
ALLOCATED TO LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS AND THAT'S THE
WAY THAT WE- CONTINUE TO ROLL
OUT MOST OF THOSE GRANTS- EIGHT
WITH RESPECT TO- INVESTMENTS IN
INFRASTRUCTURE AT THEIR-
CERTAINLY THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT. THE ADMINISTRATION AND IN
CONCERT WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND-
LOCAL GOVERNMENT IS EVALUATING-
WE HAD AGREED TO A BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL AND THAT JULY
BUDGET. FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH TO DO AN
EVALUATION AND A LOOK AT WHERE
THOSE NEEDS ARE. AND THE- THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IT WAS
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET
BEGINNING NEXT YEAR- THE
ANALYSIS IS BEING DONE AS PART
OF THAT- BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL
WILL- INFORMANT THE
ALLOCATIONS- FOR THE THREE
HUNDRED NO I APPRECIATE THAT
BUT OF THE MONEY THAT'S BEEN
ALLOCATED IN THIS BUDGET FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ARE YOU
TELLING ME THAT. NONE OF THAT
IS GOING TO GO TOWARD THAT
PURPOSE. IT DEPENDS BECAUSE WE
DON'T NECESSARILY CONTROL HOW
LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS
ALLOCATE THEIR RESOURCES SO
THERE'S CERTAINLY- COULD SPEND
THE SITE YOU KNOW. PART OF THAT
SIZEABLE YOU KNOW OUTLAY OF
FEDERAL FUNDS FOR-
INFRASTRUCTURE POTENTIALLY BUT
OKAY AND I THINK THAT ALL OF
THIS FUNDS IS GOING ON TO THE
LOCALS AND NONE OF ITS BEING
RETAINED BY THE STATE. JUST
REALLY WHICH IS THE PATHS PASS
THROUGH. THE MAJORITY IS GOING
TO LOCAL CULTURE CONTINUES
VINDICATE THE ROUGH PERCENTAGE
ARE WE TALKING 80% 60% NINETY
FIVE PERCENT. HISTORICALLY IT'S
SOMETHING LIKE SEVENTY THIRTY
BUT I WOULDN'T WANT TO COMMIT
TO THAT NO NO NO I MEAN A
PROCLAMATION OKAY I I'M NOT
GONNA HOLD YOU LIKE- WELL
THIRTY THIRTY ONE SOMETHING SO.
YEAH WELL SOMETHING LIKE THE LC
GRAND IT'S BEEN SEVEN OKAY SO
THERE IS A STATE ACTUALLY OF
THE HALF A BILLION ACTUALLY.
ROUGHLY 30% YOU KNOW COULD BE
TWENTY FIVE TO BE THIRTY. FIVE
OR SOMETHING SOMEWHERE AROUND
THAT IS. SO I THINK WOULD BE
HELPFUL IS THAT AGAIN
APPRECIATE- THE FEDERAL FUNDING
THE ALLOCATION AND THAT I HOPE
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION WILL BE
REPORTING BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND TO THE ALLEY-
ON EXACTLY HOW THESE FUNDS ARE
SPENT AND- PARTICULARLY AGAIN.
APPRECIATE WE NEED TO USE MANY
OF THE- MUCH OF THIS FOR DIRECT
SERVICES GIVEN THE ACTIVE
NATURE OF COVE IT. BUT ALSO-
WHAT WE'RE DOING FOR THE
INFRASTRUCTURE PART WHICH BY
THE WAY ALSO RESPONSIBILITY TO
AFTER ALL YOU KNOW THAT. COULD
YOU NEED TO FAX DATA. RESULTS
IS A VERY INEFFICIENT USE OF
STAFF IN TIME SO. I HOPE THAT I
CAN GET A COMMITMENT FROM FROM
FINANCE THAT YOU'LL BE.
REPORTING BACK TO THE LA- INTO
LEGISLATURE AS TO EXACTLY HOW
THESE FUNDS WERE. DISPENSING
HOW IT HOW THEY WERE SPENT.
YEAH WE'VE BEEN WORK ON A
QUARTERLY. BY WHICH WE UPDATE
ON THE- YOU KNOW UNANTICIPATED
FEDERAL FUNDS AFTER THE DEPART
OF PUBLIC HEALTH GIVEN
DISPENSATION INCREASE AND SO WE
DO- WHEN WE PROVIDE THOSE
UPDATES WE- TRY TO PROVIDE AS
MUCH INFORMATION AS WE HAVE
AVAILABLE ON ON. HOW ON THEIR
INTENDED USE. OKAY WELL- DID
YOU GET TO HAVE MORE- YOU SAID
INTENDED USE I MEAN I
UNDERSTAND THE FEDS HAVE
PARTICULAR REQUIREMENTS BUT
IT'D BE GOOD IF YOU CAN OUTLINE
WHAT THOSE ARE SO I APPRECIATE
THAT THESE ITEMS ARE HERE THAT
ARE KIND OF LARGE BUCKETS- BUT
I'M HOPING THAT- WE CAN FOLLOW
UP AND GET MORE SPECIFICS AS TO
HOW THESE FUNDS ARE GOING TO BE
ALLOCATED AND HOW THEY CAN HELP
STRENGTHEN OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
RESPONSE. THANK YOU. THE THANK
YOU AND CENTER PANEL. LET'S GO
TO SENATOR NIELSEN. MADAM
PRESIDENT LAYS DOWN THE CENTER
I HAVE A FEW MORE MAYBE BUDGET
RELATED QUESTIONS BUT I THINK-
FOREGO THOSE JUST TO PROFFER A-
CLOSING OBSERVATION. THERE ARE
THREE BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT.
EXECUTIVE BRANCHES ONE IN THE
LEGISLATIVE AS ONE AND THE
JUDICIAL. IT SEEMS LIKE
INCREASING THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH
SEEMSTO BE A MIND- THAT THERE
YET. THEY MAKE THEIR OWN
DECISIONS. THE GOVERNOR SUBMITS
A BUDGET TO THE LEGISLATURE WE
DO THOUSANDS OF HOURS THEN OUR
SUBCOMMITTEES AND MY THEY WORK
HARD. TRYING TO GIVE OUR A
PREMATURE. THE BUDGET. AND THEN
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE JUST WELL
WE'RE GOING TO DO IT THIS WAY
GOVERNOR WATCHED IT THAT WAY.
AND THE HECK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. THE LEGISLATURE
OVER A NUMBER OF YEARS DECADES
ACTUALLY. HAVE REGULARLY SEATED
MORE OF OUR AUTHORITY
LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY OR RATHER
MORE IMPORTANTLY THE PEOPLE'S
AUTHORITY WE REPRESENT TO THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH LET THEM
DECIDE LET THEM DO IT. DON'T
CHALLENGE THE GOVERNOR MY GOSH.
WE'VE JUST HEARD MANY EXAMPLES
IS VERY NICE. THE MEMBERS HERE
WHO WORKED VERY HARD. TO GET
CERTAIN THINGS. THAT WOULD BE
LEGISLATIVE INPUT INTO THIS
BUDGET. YOU HAVE TO BE FINDING
OUT THE WELL THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE WANTS TO DO THIS. AND
THIS IS THE GOVERNOR'S PRIORITY.
I'M SORRY GOVERNOR YOU ARE NOT
THE DICTATOR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE YOU ARE NOT THE SOLE
ARBITER OF WHAT GOES IN THE
BUDGET WE APPRECIATE YOU WE-
ENJOY WORKING WITH YOU. WELL
I'M ACTUALLY NOT ENJOYING IT SO
MUCH ANYMORE. SO I DO HOPE THAT.
AND I DO SEE THAT THE MORE
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE NOW
ASSERTING LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY
THE AUTHORITY OF THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. IF WE DON'T HAVE
ANY GREATER EXAMPLE. IT WOULD
BE D. D. D. HOW THEY HAVE A
GRIEVE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS. OVER YEARS. AND
THAT AGENCY IS ABSOLUTELY AND
CAPABLE. RESPOND AND FRANKLY
WITH THE LEGISLATORS HAVE NOT
DONE ENOUGH JOB OF REORGANIZING
SHAKING UP THAT DEPARTMENT TOP
TO BOTTOM. A CLOSE IN OBSERVING
THERE IS A LEGISLATIVE BRANCH
WE- REPRESENT ABOUT A MILLION
PEOPLE. AND I THINK THAT THEY
HERE AND WE MUST NOT CONTINUE
TO DEFER TO THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH. I HAVE- I'VE NOTICED MY
EXCEPT FOR SENATOR DOLLY
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR MCGUIRE IS
THERE ANYONE I MISSED. OKAY
SENATOR DOLLY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR REAL QUICK QUESTION ON
EDUCATION FOR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- HAD A CALL WITH ALL MY
SUPERINTENDENTS BUT WE ALSO
WANT TO JUST CONFIRM THAT- IS
DISTANCE LEARNING ACCOUNTED FOR
ADA. IN THIS BUDGET AND THEN
ALSO INDEPENDENT STUDY. YEAH
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION I'M
GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO
JESSICA HOLMES OF MORE DETAILS
ON INDEPENDENT STUDY. THANK YOU
JESSICA HOLMES DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO- IT IT'LL DEPENDS A
LITTLE BIT ON YOUR DEFINITION
OF DISTANCE LEARNING BUT IF
YOU'RE REFERRING TO ZOOM ZOOM
IN ON LINE INSTRUCTION- THE
ERROR YOU HAVE WHATEVER DEVICE.
OR PLATFORM IS USED- THEN YES
THAT CAN BE PART OF AN
INDEPENDENT STUDY PROGRAM- THE
ONLY OPTION- THE ONLY THE ONLY
CABBIE OUGHT TO THAT IS IF
YOU'RE NOT USING IN THE CONTEXT
OF COURSE BASED INDEPENDENT
STUDY PROGRAM AT THE DOES NEED
TO BE. A WORK PRODUCT AND
PHYSICAL WORK PRODUCT FROM
STUDENTS IN ORDER TO COUNT-
TOWARDS THE TIME NEEDED TO EARN
AN AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE
BUT- NOT ONLY IS ONLINE
INSTRUCTION AND SEE CHRIS
INSTRUCTION ALLOWED.
INDEPENDENT STUDIES ACTUALLY
REQUIRED- IN THE LAW- DEPENDING
ON THE AGE GROUP OF THE
STUDENTS BEING TAUGHT- K.
THROUGH THREE STUDENTS ARE
REQUIRED TO BE PROVIDED- DAILY
SYNCHRONOUS INSTRUCTION- VISION
ABOUT THE GREATEST INCREASE- IT
DECREASES- IN HIGH SCHOOL. IT'S
ONCE WEEKLY- OPTION FOR AND-
AND SECRETS INSTRUCTION. LET'S
JUST IN REFLECTION OF THE
UNIQUE NEEDS OF HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THAT AND STUDY- SO THE SHORT
ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION IS YES
AS LONG AS IT IS- ACCOMPANIED
BY A WORK PRODUCT. THAT MEETS
THE REQUIREMENTS OF INDEPENDENT
STUDY. AND THAT AND THAT'S I
JUST WANT TO BE REAL CLEAR
BECAUSE THIS WAS VERY. FAST
VERY POINTEDLY BECAUSE- FOR IF
YOU HAVE A- OUTBREAK OF COVE IT
IN THE LAST YEAR THEY HAD THE
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO. DO
INDEPENDENT STUDY. AND MANAGE
THEIR CASES I SHOULD SAY. AND A
LOT OF STUDENTS PREFERRED TO DO
INDEPENDENT STUDY SO. I KNOW
PREVIOUS. TO I BELIEVE THIS
TRAILER BILL. WE WEREN'T
WEREN'T ABLE TO DO THAT SO I
WANT TO MAKE SURE BECAUSE MY-
SUPERINTENDENTS WANT TO HAVE
THAT FLEXIBILITY. SO THEY CAN
MANAGE. THEIR COVERED OUTBREAKS
AND STILL GET THE ADA THEY'RE
HAVING A HECK OF  TIME-
MEETING THEIR BUDGETS WITH THE
AMOUNT OF- STILL STOOD-
TEACHERS THAT- AT THE FILLING
TEACHERS AND CAN'T THINK OF A
NAME RIGHT NOW BUT- ANYWAY
GETTING GETTING NO SUBSTITUTE
AND SO THAT'S IT WAS IT WAS THE
NUMBER ONE QUESTION FROM
THROUGHOUT MY NINE COUNTIES
FROM THE SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS IF THEY HAVE THAT
FLEXIBILITY TO MAKE SURE THEY
GET THE ADA. THAT WAS OBVIOUSLY
A POINT OKAY. NO PROBLEM
SENATOR MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH READING CHAIR UP. PERSON
FOR MOST- YEAH YOU KNOW THAT
THERE IS FRUSTRATION AND SO
MANY FOLKS ARE TIRED BASED OFF
OF THE FIRE IS THAT SO MANY
COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN FACING. I
THINK CALIFORNIA IS TRULY THE
CANARY IN THE COAL MINE. WHEN
IT COMES TO THE ISSUES OF
WILDFIRES HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA. IT'S NOT
JUST THE CLIMATE CRISIS BUT
THIS CLIMATE CRISIS IS ADDING
TO THE CRISIS AT THE STATE
FACES. EACH AND EVERY SUMMER
AND FALL. I THINK THAT PROTEIN
MACHEN'S CHAIR SKINNER RIGHT
CASKEY PURCHASE UP TO CHEER AND
THE GOVERNOR HELP LEAD THIS
STATE WITH RECORD FUNDING
EARLIER THIS YEAR RECORD
FUNDING FOR WILDFIRE PREVENTION
ADDITIONAL FOURTEEN HUNDRED
SEASONAL FIREFIGHTERS HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
WILDFIRE PREVENTION FUNDING.
NEVER BEFORE HAS THE GOLDEN
STATE INVESTED AS MUCH ON
WILDFIRE PREVENTION RESPONSE
AND WE HAVE THIS YEAR. BUT IS
ALSO INCREDIBLY CLEAR. COMING
FROM A REGION OF THE STATE THAT
HAS THE FIRST MILLION ACRE FIRE.
WHERE A COUNTY LIKE LAKE HAS
TWO THIRDS OF HIS LAND MASS
BURN SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
THAT WE ARE IN DESPERATE NEED
FOR A LONG TERM STRATEGIC PLAN
ASSOCIATED WITH WILDFIRE
PREVENTION AND RESPONSE. AND I
KNOW THAT I SOUND LIKE A BROKEN
RECORD EACH AND EVERY BUDGET
CYCLE. BUT CAL FIRE ACTUALLY.
PEAKED WITH STAFFING BACK IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE. NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE NOW I WILL SAY NO
OTHER GOVERNOR HAS INVESTED
MORE ON CAL FIRE AND WHAT FIRE
PREVENTION THE ONE THAT WE HAVE
HERE TODAY THE GOVERNOR'S. AND.
OUR RESOURCES ARE STRETCHED THE
MEN AND WOMEN ON THE FRONT
LINES OF THESE WILDLAND FIRES
ARE EXHAUSTED AND WE NEED TO
TAKE A LOOK AT A LONG TERM PLAN
WHEN IT COMES OF FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT FIREFIGHTER
POSITIONS WERE STILL TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY ONE FIREFIGHTER
SHORT FULL TIME OF THAT PLANE
BEANS HAVE FAILED. AND WE CAN'T
CONTINUE TO RELY ON SEASONAL
FIREFIGHTERS ARE WORKING TEN
MONTHS OUT OF THE YEAR. NOT
RECEIVING THE SAME PAY WHICH
CAN REALLY ADD CHALLENGES WITH.
IN THE SAME WORKFORCE
PROTECTIONS. SO WHAT I WOULD
HOPE IS THAT. THROUGH THE
LEADERSHIP OF CHAIRMAN CASKEY
WHO'S BEEN ON THIS ISSUE THE
LEADERSHIP AFTER SKINNER. WHO
I'M GRATEFUL FOR HER DIGGING
INTO THIS ALONG WITH THE PRO
TEAM THAT WE ARE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO DEVELOP A LONGER TERM
PLAN TO BE ABLE TO INVEST IN
WILDFIRE PREVENTION LONGER
TERM. WHICH THE SENATE HAS LED
WITH THE BOND- AND HOW WE'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO BRING THE
CAL FIRE RANGE TO WHERE IT
SHOULD BE- TO MEET THE MODERN
NEEDS AT THE GOLDEN STATE BUT I
JUST WANTED TO SAY MADAM CHAIR.
WELL I KNOW WE'RE IN THE THICK
OF IT FOR THE LAST FEW DAYS OF
SESSION BUT TENSIONS ARE HIGH
BUT WE ALSO CAN'T FORGET HOW
FAR WE'VE ALSO COME THIS YEAR.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO THE
INVESTMENT AMOUNT FOR
PREVENTION RESPONSE. AND IT'S
CLEARLY NOT ENOUGH AND MORE
WORK TO DO. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR MCGUIRE LET ME SEE.
ANY OTHER MIKES UP OKAY- I- WE
WILL HEAR FROM THE PUBLIC AND
AT THE RISK OF THE WRATH OF
SOME OF YOU I THE LOOK WITH
THIS IS THE LAST WEEK OF
SESSION AND IT DOES GET TESTY.
AND THERE ARE NO ACTION THAT WE
TAKE WHETHER ITS BUDGETARY OR
LEGISLATIVE SATISFIES EVERYONE
NOR DID IT EVEN THOSE OF US
WHO. WERE MOST INTIMATELY
INVOLVED IN THE NEGOTIATIONS
WE'RE IT'S GIVE OR TAKE THERE'S
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
LEGISLATORS AND THERE'S AN
ADMINISTRATION BUT I WOULD SAY.
THAT IF WE TAKE THIS PACKAGE
FOR EXAMPLE OR THE SET OF BILLS
BEFORE. US AS SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE KEY POINTED OUT. B. ADMIN.
ONLY HAD PROPOSED. A BILLION
FOR CRIME REGION. WHAT WE WILL
VOTING ON TODAY THIS POINT FIVE
BILLION. NOW IT IS AND SPEND IT
ALL FIRST YEAR BUT WE WOULDN'T
BE ABLE TO SPEND THAT AMOUNT IN
THE FIRST YEAR. SO I THINK THAT
WE- IT'S OKAY TO BE FRUSTRATED
AND EXPRESSES FRUSTRATIONS BUT
I ALSO DO NOT WANT US TO LOSE
SIGHT OF THE INCREDIBLE THINGS
THAT WE ARE DOING. WITH THIS
WITH THE BUDGET WE'VE ALREADY
ADOPTED THE APPROPRIATIONS YOU
MADE AND NOW WITH THIS TRAILER
BILLS TO GET THAT MONEY. ON TO
THE STREET AND ITO THE
PROGRAMS TO. CUT TO CHALLENGE
THE CLIMATE CRISIS WERE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THAT'S WHY WE HAVE
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN ALL YEAR
ROUND FIRES NOW. AND THIS
ACTION IS THAT WE HAVE BEFORE
US WOULD GET THAT MONEY TO ST
PERHAPS NOT AS FAST AS EVERYONE
WANTED BUT IT IS APPROVED IT IS
APPROPRIATING A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT YES WE WILL NEED MORE
WORK FORCE AND- HOPEFULLY WILL
HELP PROTECT REVENUES IN THIS
UPCOMING YEAR TO DO THAT. AND
WE WERE ARE BEGINNING TO
ADDRESS THE FACT THAT NOW THAT
WE'RE IN THE MIDST OF THE
CLIMATE CRISIS WERE FEELING IT
DAILY THE WE'VE GOT TO ADAPT.
WE'VE UP TO RECENTLY FOCUSED
PRIMARILY ON TRYING TO REDUCE
THE EMISSIONS THAT CAUSE IT BUT
WE'RE IN THE MIDST OF IT. SO
THE RESILIENCY PACKAGE IS AN
ADAPTATION PACKAGE AND WE HAVE
NEVER PUT FUNDS TOWARDS THAT
AND THEN NO ONE MADE THIS
COMMENT TONIGHT BUT THERE'S
ANOTHER REALLY GREAT THING. IN
THE HIGHER EDUCATION ACTIONS
BEFORE US WE ARE GOING TO BE
AUTHORIZING. FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION. FOR STUDENT HOUSING.
WE HAVE A HOUSING CRISIS
EVERYONE HERE KNOWLEDGE IS ****
AND WE HAVE STUDENTS NOW THAT
LIVE IN VEHICLES THAT COUCH
SURF. BETTER HOMELESS
ESPECIALLY WITHIN OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM. AND WE'RE GOING
TO BEGIN. TO ADDRESS THAT BY
PARTNERING WITH OUR HIGHER ED
INSTITUTIONS TO BUILD STUDENT
HOUSING WHICH WE HAVEN'T DONE
IN A LONG TIME SO THERE IS A
LOT OF GREAT THINGS. IN THESE
ACTIONS AND THE OVERALL
WILDFIRE PACKAGE JUST FOR THIS
YEAR ALONE IS ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION IN SPENDING SO. LET US
TURN TO THE PUBLIC NOW THEY MAY
HAVE. SOME OTHER FRUSTRATIONS
OR PERHAPS THEY HAVE SOME
THINGS THEY'D LIKE TO
CELEBRATE. SO THERE IS NO ONE
IN OUR HEARING ROOM OR I WOULD
CALL ON THEM. AND THERE'S NO
ONE IN OUR AUXILIARY ROOM SO
THAT MEANS WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
FROM PEOPLE CALLING IN. THE
PHONE NUMBER FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO WANT TO CALL IN IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN THREE THREE SIX
pACCESS CODE IS. EIGHT TWO SIX
EIGHT FOUR TWO EIGHT- SO- OR
OPERATOR DO WE HAVE SOME PEOPLE
NOW ON THE PHONE LINES AND
COULD YOU TELL ME HOW MANY ARE
QUEUED UP. AND LATER GERMAN IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENTS PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN
ONE ZERO OR BY COMMENTS. AT
THIS TIME WE DO ABOUT TWENTY IN
THE QUEUE ALL RIGHT GREAT LET'S
START. AND A POLITICIAN BUT
THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE CALLING IN
WE APPRECIATE GIVEN THE TIME
AND THAT WE HAVE TO VOTE ON.
SIXTEEN BILLS THAT- YOU CAN
MAKE YOUR POINTS AS
EXPEDITIOUSLY AS POSSIBLE THANK
YOU GO AHEAD. WE'LL START WITH
NUMBER EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS CONNIE DELGADO ON
BEHALF THE DISTRICT HOSPITAL
LEADERSHIP FOREMAN THE THIRTY
THREE DIFFERENT HOSPITALS WE
REALLY LIKE TO THANK YOU- THE
BIKE SHARING ADMINISTRATION AND
MEMBERS OF YOUR STAFF
THE BRIDGE LOAN PROGRAM NF B.
AND AB ONE SEVENTY EIGHTY
FRANKEL PROVIDE CASH FLOW. PER
DISTRICT HOSPITALS THAT THEY
TRANSITION FROM THE CURRENT THE
Q. I. P. PROGRAM AND WE HOPE TO
CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS HERE ON
HOW WE WILL CONTINUE TO PARK
CALIFORNIA. TO TALK ABOUT THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU. I WANNA
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
PRODUCT CARE DELIVERS CRUISE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA COURT
ACTION FUND. CALLING TO
REGISTER OUR SUPPORT FOR AV SP
ONE SIXTY TWO WHICH CREATES THE
COMMUNITY ECONOMIC RESILIENCE
AND PROGRAM SUPPORT REGIONAL
ECONOMIC REBUILDING WE ALSO
WANT TO EXTEND OUR DEEP
APPRECIATION TO STAFF WHO
WORKED ON THE PROPOSAL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. WINDS. FIFTEEN
GOOD EVENING TURN MEMBERS AND I
THINK ABOUT THE KEY STRATEGIES
ON BEHALF OF SAN JOSE MAYOR SAM
LICCARDO IN SUPPORT OF THE FUEL
CELL NOT ENERGY MEDIA METERING
EXTENSION INCLUDING EIGHTY ONE
FIFTY FIVE ADDITIONALLY ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN JOSE
AND FOR PART OF THE SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN EIGHTY ONE
TEN EACH PROGRAM TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO IMPACT THE
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
COMMUNICATION. FINALLY ON
BEHALF OF THE DOCTOR TURNED
COLLISION WITH OPPOSITION AND
CONCERN WITH EIGHTY ONE FIFTY
FIVE WE ARE CONCERNED WITH THE
PRIVACY CLOUD COMPUTING FOR
BIODIVERSITY PROJECT AND THE
FACT THAT IT COULD POTENTIALLY
INCLUDE THE DENTAL. DELTA
TUNNELS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
IN LINE. FORTY FOUR. GOOD
EVENING CHEERING MEMBERS ERIC
ROMERO THE HELP OF THE HISPANIC
ASSOCIATION OF COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES CALLING ON EIGHTY
ONE SIXTY NINE THE HIGHER
EDUCATION TRAILER BILL WE SENT
A LETTER TO THE COMMITTEE BUT
WANTED TO STRESS THAT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING FUNDING SOON
FOR THE HIGHER EDUCATION
CAPACITY EXPANSION GRANT
PROGRAM WHICH IS NOT CURRENTLY
FUNDED IN THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. BLIND. FORTY SIX.
GOOD EVENING CARE MEMBERS
JENNIFER VALLEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
JUST WANTED TO THANK YOU FOR
THE TIRELESS EFFORTS BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE COMMITTEE'S
FASHION BO APPS ON THE BUDGET
CLEANUP BILLS THAT WERE
RECENTLY RELEASED AND CHECK ON
A COUPLE ITEMS TO NOTE ON A. B.
S. B. ONE SEVENTY TWO AND THE
IN HOME SUPPORT SERVICES CAREER
PATHWAYS TRAINING IT'LL PROVIDE
TRAINING WITH INCENTIVES TO
CREATE OPPORTUNITIES FOR CAREER
ADVANCEMENT THE HOME CARE AND
HEALTHCARE INDUSTRIES- AND
LASTLY JUST WANTED TO EXPRESS
OUR APPRECIATION FOR- YOUR WORK
ON A. ONE. TEACH YOU THE
COMMUNITY ECONOMIC RESILIENCE
FUND AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND THAT UNION JOBS
PROVIDE QUALITY JOBS WITH
LIVABLE WAGES AND IT'S AN
IMPORTANT PART OF WHICH I THINK
EQUITY IN THE WORKFORCE WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND REVIEW FUTURE
REPORTS ON GRANT AWARDEES AND
ANALYZING THE NUMBERS SIGNATORY
EMPLOYERS WITH BARGAINING
AGREEMENT AND THE NUMBER OF
UNION JOBS VERSUS NON UNION JOB
THAT PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROGRAM. AS WE TRY TO BUILD
BACK OUR WORKFORCE. THANK YOU
HAVE A WONDERFUL EVENING. BLIND
FIFTY. GOOD EVENING- AND
MEMBERS ME MOCK ON BEHALF OF
THE CENTER FOR FOOD SAFETY WE
WISH TO THANK YOU FOR FINDING
IN THE HEALTHY SOILS PROGRAM
THE POLLINATOR HABITAT PROGRAM
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR
CONSERVATION MANAGEMENT AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO ENSURING THE
CONSERVATION MANAGEMENT PLANS
INCLUDED SUPPORT ORGANIC
TRANSITION PLAN. THANK YOU
AGAIN. ONE FIFTY ONE. GOOD
EVENING CARE MEMBERS PRISCILLA
KIDDER COUNTY HAVE TO STOP WAIT
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT SAMPLE
PROBABLY THE STATION OF NORTH
AMERICA ON STRONG SUPPORT AT
EIGHTY ONE SEVENTY EIGHT THAT
CLEAN THE ALLOCATIONS MADE TO
SECULAR CONNIE PACKAGE AND THE
ONE THIRTY MILLION TOWARD AT
THE THIRTY THREE REGULATIONS WE
APPRECIATE THAT WORK ON THIS
ALONG WITH SENATOR LEAHY AND
SENATOR WHITE COUNTY TO SECURE
THE FUNDING ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY THE SOLANO AND SAN
JOAQUIN WE AREN'T THE POOR AT
SECTION TWENTY SIX OF EIGHTY
ONE SEVENTY REGARDING THE
EXTENSION FOR THE COMMUNITY
SERVICES. INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT
PROGRAM TO JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY THREE WE
APPRECIATE BUDGET COMMITTEE
STAFF. TO WORK ON THE CELL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE.
FIFTY TWO. GOOD EVENING LINDA
AWAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY FIRSTLY WHEN I
THINK BACK IN COMMITTEE ALL
YOUR WORK AND WANTED TO EXPRESS
OUR APPRECIATION FOR MULTIPLE
BILLS INCLUDING ONE FIFTY FIVE
WHICH EXTENDS THE WATER SHUT
OFF MORATORIUM AND WE ENCOURAGE
A SIMILAR EXTENSION FOR RENTAL
ASSISTANCE ONE SIXTY G. WHICH
INCREASES FUNDING FOR
TRANSCRIPT INVESTMENT FUND ONE
SEVENTY WHICH PROVIDES FUNDING
FOR AFGHAN REFUGEES BUT STILL
NEED FUNDING FOR EXISTING
REFUGEES. ONE SEVENTY ONE WHICH
PROVIDES AN EVALUATION OF
WHETHER THAT STATE HAS ENOUGH
HOUSING SUPPORT SERVICE
PROVIDERS FOR FUTURE MEDICARE
HEALTH BENEFIT ONE SEVENTY TWO
WHICH INCREASE YOUR HOUSEWORK
INCOME DISREGARD FOR APPLICANTS
ONE SEVENTY SIX WHICH LIMITS
COLLECTIONS FOR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES ND ONE SEVENTY
SEVENTY WHICH WERE KILLED
COMMUNITY BAND COLLECTION OF
THESE FEES AND INCREASES
FUNDING. FOR COURT REPORTERS
THANK YOU. THANK BLIND. FIFTY
THREE. GOOD EVENING SURE
SKINNER NUMBERS THEY'RE TALKING
HAPPILY GIVE CALIFORNIA CITIES
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF A NUMBER
OF ITEMS ON BOTH ATSC ONE
SEVENTY A MONTH FIFTY FIVE IN A
DETAIL THOSE ITEMS IN OUR
LETTERS WILL BE SUBMITTED TO
THE COMMITTEE BUT IN PARTICULAR
WANT TO KNOW EACH OTHER WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
INCLUSION IN THE EIGHT BST ONE
SEVENTY AND SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
TO IMPLEMENT ACCOUNT RECYCLING
SPEAKER JIMMY THREE ORGANIC
WASTE DIVERSION REGULATIONS AND
THESE FUNDS WILL HELP LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS GET THEIR SP
THIRTEEN THREE PROGRAMS AND
RUNNING. TO HELP REDUCE METHANE
EMISSIONS AND FOOD WASTE IN OUR
CITIES WE WANT TO THANK YOU THE
FAMILY MEMBER CHANG AND SANDERS
WHITE COUNTY AND WHERE AND ALL
THE STAFF FOR THEIR HARD WORK
IN SECURING FUNDING THEY'RE
GRATEFUL FOR THIS DOWN PAYMENT
FROM THE STATE WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING FUTURE
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT INITIAL
FUNDING TO HELP HELPING CITY
GOVERNMENT. SUPPORT PROGRAM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
ONE FORTY ONE. GOOD EVENING
CHURCH DINNER AND MEMBERS HAVE
ALREADY ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
OR CALL CORRECTED THE
TECHNICIAN WITH THE NAVY AT THE
ONE SEVENTY WERE APPRECIATIVE
OF THE APPROPRIATION THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICE PLAN AND
PHARMACEUTICALS CONTRACTOR THAT
SUPPORTS FOUR TERM RESIDENTIAL
THERAPEUTIC PROGRAM OVER
SIXTEEN BAD BATTERY
KNOWLEDGEABLE AND RECEIVING
FEDERAL FUNDING AND DIRECTED
THEM IN TRANSITIONING THEIR
PROGRAM TO CONTINUE TO BE ABLE
TO RECEIVE FEDERAL FUNDING
OTHER WINNERS KNOWLEDGE THAT
THEY NEED IN THIS AREA NOT AN
TO ATTRACT THE TOTAL LOSS IN
FEDERAL FUNDING. WE SUPPORT THE
OPERATING LANGUAGE FOR FEDERAL
FINANCING FOR MENTAL HEALTH
RECEIVED THE ASKING EIGHTY THE
ONE SEVENTY AS WELL WE SUPPORT
THE CREDIT SIDE- PERSONAL
COUNTY WITHIN THE COMMUNITY
CARE ENGINE PROGRAM UNDER THE
HUMAN SERVICES TRAILER BILLING
PLEDGE. YEAH HE WON SEVENTY Q.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WINDS
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
JENNIFER FEARING AND I'LL BE
HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF MUSEUMS ARE
ALMOST A HUNDRED CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS AND TWENTY TWO
LEGISLATORS ADVOCATED FOR
FUNDING TO PROTECT CULTURAL AND
HISTORIC ASSETS FROM KIND OF AN
IMPACT ON THE CLIMATE CHANGE
EDUCATION MUSEUMS SCIENCE
CENTERS DO THE KOREANS AND THE
LIKE NOTE THAT WE WILL CONTINUE.
ON BEHALF OF AN ATLANTA EDITION
AND NATIONAL WILDLIFE
FEDERATION WE APPRECIATE THE
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY THREE
MILLION AND EIGHTY ONE SEVENTY
OVER THE NEXT THREE YEARS.
ROBERT CONSERVATION. PROJECTS
THAT INCLUDE ROBERT CROSSINGS
AND CONNECTIVE ITTY SIMILARLY
OCEAN CONSERVANCY WAS HAPPY TO
SEE FUNDING FOR THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL. AND LASTLY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FISHING GAME WARDEN SUPERVISORS
AND MANAGERS ASSOCIATION AND
THE CALIFORNIA ROBERT AFTER
THAT THOUGH THE EXAMINATION TO
GIVE ME. THANK YOU FOR THE
APPROPRIATION TO CREATE TWENTY
NINE ADDITIONAL P. RIBA HOW
COMBAT ENVIRONMENTAL DAMAGE
CAUSED BY ILLEGAL CANNABIS
CULTIVATION. THANK YOU FOR ALL
YOUR HARD WORK. THANK YOU. LINE.
SIXTY FOUR. GOOD EVENING KAREN
NUMBERS ARE BACK IN MARKET
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE BRADY
CAMPAIGN AND STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY ONE SEVENTY THREE THE
DATA SHARING PROVISION WILL
PLAY A CRUCIAL ROLE IN THE
ANALYSIS ULTIMATELY USED TO
PREVENT THE LOSS OF LIFE DUE TO
GUN VIOLENCE ON BEHALF OF
AMERICAN FARMLAND TRUST CARBON
CYCLE INSTITUTE AND THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE AGRICULTURE
NETWORK REGARDING EIGHTY ONE
SEVENTY I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE LARGE
OVERALL INVESTMENT HEALTHY
SOIL. FINDING FOR SWEEP AND THE
CONSERVATION PLANNING GRANT
PROGRAM AND THE FUNDING FOR
PRIORITIZATION OF ANNA HOWEVER
WE WOULD LIKE TO ECHO SENATOR
WILL CALCULATE THAT THE CLAIM
THAT THE FINAL BUDGET DOES NOT
CONTAIN FUNDING FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION'S
CALIFORNIA FARMLAND AND
CONSERVANCY PROGRAM EXCUSE ME
THANK. YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
ALL YOUR HARD WORK. THANK YOU.
ONE SIXTY FIVE. GOOD EVENING
CHAIR MEMBERS GINA GOOD HOW
COME CLEAN POWER ALLIANCE
THANKS MEANING YOU AKE
AGGREGATOR REPRESENTING AN
INCORPORATED LA AND VENTURA
COUNTIES AND THIRTY THIRTY
COULD NET COUNTY. HARDLINE
TACTICS PREFERABLY SHE SHE FOR
A B. ACTS THE ONE FORTY FIVE
THE TYPICALLY SECTION FORTY
NINE FIFTY FOUR AND FIFTY FIVE.
TO ADDRESS THE STREAM HE HAD TO
FIND COMMUNITY REGARDING KEY
FACTOR. OUR COMMUNITY HAS BEEN
TAKING THE GROWING THREAT OF
EXTREME HEAT THAT EXACERBATED
BY FIRE AND PLANT UNPLANNED
POWER OUTAGES. AND WE ARE
ALREADY WORKING WITH THE
COMMUNITY TO CREATE WITH
NINETEEN FACTORS AND OTHER
MEASURES BUT OUR COMMUNITY VERY
MUCH NEED ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITY. FOR FINDING YOUR
CORRECT ENGLISH AND. ONE SIXTY
SIX. GOOD EVENING MEMBERS
CATHOLIC WOMEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES THE STOCK ALONG WITH A
COLLEAGUE WITH URBAN AND RURAL
COUNTY ASSOCIATION WOULD LIKE
TO ACKNOWLEDGE ALL THE HARD
WORK THAT WENT IN FOR A LANDING
AN ADDITIONAL ROUND OF CRIMINAL
JUSTICE BE REPEALED HERE WE
BELIEVE THAT THE AB ONE SEVEN
SEVEN REPRESENT THE WRITTEN
LANDING SPOT AND APPRECIATE
THEIR ONGOING COUNTY REVENUE%
POSSIBLE THE CONCLUDED. WE
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO REGISTER OUR
STRONG SUPPORT WITH FIFTY
MILLION FOR LOCAL JURISDICTION
FOR EMPLOYMENT AT THE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE ORGANIC WASTE
DIVERSION REGULATIONS AND
THOROUGHLY THANK SENATORS
LAYERED AND MY COFFEE OR
HELPING TO SECURE THE FUNDING
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR CONTRACT WITH
THE CORPORATION FOR CAL FIRE
FOR HEALTHY PEOPLE OR SOME FIRE
PREVENTION PROGRAMS THE
TRAINING AS YOU HEARD IT'S
CRITICALLY NECESSARY FOR
ONGOING- FIRE PREVENTION FOR
ALL. TYPES OF PROJECTS THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR WORK. THANK
YOU. ONE SIXTY NINE. GOOD
EVENING ASKING ME FINISH AT THE
COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY
FARMERS CAFE I WANTED TO THANK
YOU CHEERS SKINNER AND MEMBERS
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP PROVIDING
FUNDING FOR PROGRAMS AND CHANGE
THE COMMUNITY FOOD HUBS PROGRAM
BEGINNING FARMER PROGRAM AND
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
FOR HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED
FARMERS WE ALSO WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT THE DROP PRICES TO
CONTINUE THAT CONTINUES TO PUT
FIRST SMALL SCALE FARMERS IN A
DESPERATE SITUATION AND I WANT
TO CONTINUE OUR WORK TO
PRIORITIZE INVESTMENTS EARLY
FIFTIES FARMERS WHO THIS WEEK
PROGRAM ANOTHER INVESTMENT.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR HARD
WORK. THANK YOU. GOOD EVENING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS KRISTIE
BELL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS I WOULD LIKE TO
ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH US
SENATOR A BROKEN RECORD MCGUIRE
ON THE CAL FIRE STAFFING NEEDS
AND LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH. EACH OF YOU TO
BRING RESOLUTION TO THAT
CHALLENGE IN THAT DEPARTMENT
AND.
CONSENTED TO TEACHERS FROM
THIRTY TO SIXTY DAYS THE
PROVISIONS TO PROVIDE REMOTE
LEARNING AND QUARANTINE ALL OF
THE QUARANTINE STUDENTS AND
FUNDING TO DO SO FROM THE FIRST
DAY OF THE STUDENT QUARANTINE
WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION LEGISLATURES
AFRICAN RECENT BUDGET TO
PROVIDE EDUCATOR ATTENTION AND
TRAINING WHICH ARE EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT DURING THE ONGOING
SCHOOL EMPLOYEE SHORTAGE. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS WITH YOU
REGARDING IMPLEMENTATION OF
BEES AND OTHER PROVISIONS IN AB
SP ONE SIXTY SEVEN AND EIGHTY
ONE THIRTY DURING THE INTERIM
RECESS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION. MEMBERS OF MAKING.
ONE FORTY TWO. GOOD EVENING
MADAM MADAM CHAIR AND A MEMBER
GENERAL DENTAL DON'T BE HELPFUL
FOR YOU TO DEATH YOU INTO PORT
AUTHORITY PSP ONE SEVENTY TWO
WE APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE
BUDGET STAFF DEPARTMENT AND-
THAT THE MINISTRATION FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THE AGENTS
AFTER HERE PATHWAY LANGUAGE WE
LOOK FORWARD TO ONGOING
CONVERSATION ON THE PROVIDER
BACKUP SYSTEM. THANK YOU FOR
ALL YOUR WORK. ONE FORTY SEVEN.
GOOD EVENING SHARE MEMBERS ANY
LONGER WITH WIND ENERGY WE
SUPPORT THE BILL THAT EXTENSION
CONVENIENT EIGHTY F. B. ONE
FIFTY FIVE THE BOOKKEEPER
HIGHLY RESILIENT CLEAN
TECHNOLOGY AVAILABLE
CALIFORNIAN GERMANTOWN ACADEMY.
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR WORK IN
YOUR EFFORTS ON THIS. ONE
THIRTY TWO. GOOD EVENING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS MALACHI ALL
MEN WITH THE CALIFORNIA URBAN
PARTNERSHIP WE ARE ONE OF THE
FOUNDING MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS EQUITY
ALLIANCE WHICH IS A VOICE FOR
HUNDREDS OF- ENTREPRENEURS AND
ACTIVISTS AROUND THE STATE AND
THE CANNABIS SPACED WHO'VE BEEN
IMPACTED BY THE WAR ON DRUGS.
AND WE'D LIKE TO THINK OF THE
CURRENT LEADERSHIP OF BUDGET
LEADERSHIP AS WELL AS THE PAPPY
PARTICULAR- FOR MAKING CANNABIS
EQUITY- IN TERMS OF A
DEFINITION A PRIORITY FOR YOU
AT THE ONE SIXTY SIX- WE-
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CONTINUE THE DISCUSSION GROUP
REGULATION- BECAUSE THERE IS
ONE PARTICULAR ITEM BACK DOES-
CALLED HARM EXTREME HARM IF IT
DOESN'T GET CORRECTED AND THAT
IS THE FACT THAT WE HAVE. BUT
THE COUPLE AT THE COUPLING AND
THE DEFINITION THAT RELATE TO
LOW INCOME STATUS AND THAT
RELATES TO LOW INCOME
NEIGHBORHOODS IF WE SEPARATE
THOSE TWO ITEMS THEN THERE ARE
HARMS THAT ARE CREATED BECAUSE
NOT ALL- LOW INCOME PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN EXTREMELY HARMED AND
TRAUMATIZED AND PUT
INTERGENERATIONAL POVERTY
BECAUSE- OF THE WAR ON DRUGS-
AND THEN WE ALSO- WITH THE
DECOUPLING OF THAT DEFINITION-
IT CREATES A PATH FOR-
SHARECROPPER AND VULTURE
INVESTING SOMETHING THAT WE
HAVE FOUGHT VERY- TIRELESSLY
AGAIN. AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WHRE
WE HAVE BEEN RESPONSIBLE FOR
SHAPING EQUITY PROGRAMS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL BETTER INTENTIONAL
ABOUT ERASING THE UC TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY YEAR RACIAL
WEALTH GAP IN CALIFORNIA AND
ALSO PREVENTING THE THREE
BILLION DOLLAR WEALTH TRANSFER.
POWER FROM THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
MOST HARMED AND TRAUMATIZED
FROM POVERTY IMPOVERISHED
BECAUSE OF THE. WAR ON DRUGS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. M. M. CHARGES HERE
WHERE WE HAVE THIRTEEN LEFT IN
THE QUEUE. NEXT WE NUMBER.
THIRTY FIVE. GOOD EVENING ON
SHIPS ON BEHALF OF THE CAMPUS
EQUITY POLICY COUNCIL AND
TRANSPORT OF A B. S. THE ONE
SIXTY SIX WE THANK THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
FOR THEIR DEDICATION TO EMBARK
ON CANNABIS EQUITY POLICIES
WE'RE SPECIALLY PLEASED TO SEE
A MINIMUM 50% OWNERSHIP
REQUIREMENT TO QUALIFY AS AN
EQUITY APPLICANT OR LICENSEE
WHICH WE BELIEVE IS KEY TO
SUPPORTING EQUITY ENTREPRENEURS
AS THEY WORK. TOWARDS AND THE
INDUSTRY THANK YOU. NUMBER.
FIFTY NINE. GOOD EVENING READ
THE CONTENT WITH METROPOLITAN
WATER DISTRICT THANK YOU TO THE
BUDGET SHARE LEADERSHIP IN THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE
INCLUSION OF CROWDFUNDING
ACCESS LANGUAGES S. T. EIGHTY
ONE SEVENTY. ALSO WE WANT
EXPRESSED APPRECIATION FOR THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR RECYCLED
WATER AND GROUNDWATER
REMEDIATION AS WELL AS- APPLE
P. FIVE MEDICAL AND FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. NUMBER. TWENTY ONE.
NUMBER TWENTY ONE IS A SURE NOT
A MUTE. LOOKS LIKE THEY MAY
HAVEDISCONNECTED WE MOVED TO
NUMBER. THIRTY SEVEN. GOOD
EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- JOHN WHEN YOU'RE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHARTER SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION WE
APPRECIATE THE INCLUSION OF THE
CHARTER PROTECTED THEM WITH THE
INDEPENDENT STUDY PROVISION
WITHIN SECTION THIRTY OF EIGHTY
ONE SIXTY SEVEN. THAT WAS
NOTIFIED THE- ABS RETENTION WE
WOULD HIGHLIGHT THAT THIS
PROVISION IS NOT INCLUDED IN
THE ASSEMBLY VERSION OF THE
EDUCATION TRAILER BILL SB ONE
SIXTY SEVEN SO WE WOULD REQUEST
THAT YOU HOLD THAT BILL IF YOU
RECEIVE IT- VERY QUICKLY I
WOULD JUST NOTE THAT THIS
PROVISION IS A CRITICAL
PROTECTION FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS.
THAT LIKE IF YOU'RE GOING TO
PROVIDE QUALITY SERVICES DURING
UNEVEN AND UNPREDICTABLE COVERT
CLOSURES IN QUARANTINE THAT
HERE HOWEVER DISTRICTS. ARE NOT
SUBJECT TO THE SAME
RESTRICTIONS BY BASED CHARTER
SCHOOLS OFFERING INDEPENDENT
STUDY WITH THE PROTECTION IN
THE BATH OF BRITAIN MORE CHARGE
WILL BE INTO. IMAGINE PROGRAM
K. OFF THAT THEY WOULD BE TO
CAPS ACT THE CALL AND STUDY
PROGRAMS SCHOOL. OR STATING
BUDGETARY CUTS THAT WE THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR KNOWLEDGE OF
THIS ISSUE IN THE IN THE IN THE
STADIUM. ONE SIXTY SEVEN THANK
YOU. NUMBER. SEVENTY THREE-
GOOD EVENING THANK YOU JUSTIN
AND NUMBERS FOR SAYING LIKE
THEY'RE FROM THE PUBLIC THIS IS
STEPHEN MYERS ON BEHALF OF
MAGNETS WITH REGIONAL OPEN
SPACE DISTRICT SAVE THE
REDWOODS LEAGUE CAN PROVIDE ONE
STRONG AN TRUSTED SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY ON THE CALIFORNIA
HABITAT CONSERVATION PLAN CALLS.
FIRST WE'RE EXTREME GRATEFUL
FOR THE PEOPLE EXEMPTION AND
ADS. ONE FIFTY FIVE FOR
PROJECTS THAT PROMOTE WILDLIFE
AND HABITAT. THIS WILL HELP TO
KEEP OUR COMMON GOAL TO
STREAMLINE PROJECTS REACHED. US
OFFICIALS. WE ALSO APPRECIATE
THE COTTON DOLLARS FOR THE CITY
COASTAL CONSERVANCY SAN
FRANCISCO BAY PROGRAM WHICH
WILL SUPPORT OUR PROJECTS
THROUGHOUT THE BAY AREA. WE ARE
DISAPPOINTED HOWEVER IN THE
AMOUNT OF FUNDING FOR THE
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD IN
THE B. X. B. ONE SEVENTY. GIVEN
THE LACK OF THE BOND FUNDING
MANY OF THEIR PROGRAMS ARE
ALMOST ENTIRELY DEPLETED. AND
FINALLY WHAT WE APPRECIATE
ABOUT DOING WHICH IS MAYBE SP
ONE FIFTY FIVE I'M NOT PARTY TO
TEACH A BUDGET YEARS. WE WORRY
THAT THERE ISN'T A CALL OUT FOR
W. C. B. WHICH IS AN ESSENTIAL
PARTNER IN CLIMATE RESILIENCY
CONSERVATION PROJECTS. THAT
NEED TO BE AN ORGANIZATION'S
RETURNS BACK TO BUDGET YEARS IN
ORDER TO PLAN AND. SCHEDULE I.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NUMBER.
SEVENTY FOUR. GOOD EVENING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS BRADY
BORDERING WITH FUEL CELL ENERGY
BEING IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY ONE
FIFTY FIVE AND A TWO YEAR
EXTENSION TO THE FUEL CELL NET
ENERGY METERING PROGRAM THAT WE
THINK IS IMPORTANT TOOL FOR THE
PC TO HAVE THEIR DISPOSAL I CAN
STILL MAKE A BRIDGE BEHIND THE
METER BUT ALSO TO ADDRESS THE
SUPPLY AND DEMAND CHALLENGES IS
FACING. THE NEXT TWO YEARS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NUMBER.
THIRTY NINE. ANYTHING THAT I'M
HEARING MEMBERS AND ON BEHALF
OF YOUR ON OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
SERVICES AND RETHINK WEIGHT
CONSTRUCT A PART OF THE FUNDING
TO THE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUND THE CLERK ON THE PACKAGE
FOR ORGANICS RECYCLING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE RIGHT RELATED.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT ASSISTANCE
THANK YOU. NUMBER. SEVENTY ONE.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ELENA ORTIZ ON BEHALF
OF COMMUNITY NATURE CONNECTION
IN NATURE FOR ALL WE WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS OUR GRATITUDE FOR
THE INCLUSION OF THE
CONSERVANCY ALLOCATIONS AND
EIGHTY ONE SEVENTY WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE INCLUSION OF
FUNDING FOR STATE CONSERVANCY
TO AN EIGHTY ONE FIVE FIVE
ASSET IN COMING YEARS THIS
AMOUNT THE INCREASE AND
SPECIFIC CONSERVATIVE GET
CALLED OUT FOR THE FOLKS ON THE
GROUND TO PLAN FOR PROJECTS
ACCORDINGLY. THANK YOU. NUMBER.
SEVENTY TWO. GOOD EVENING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS
NICOLE KOREAN WITH CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE- WE'RE CONDUCT
FOR HER STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
CAL RECYCLE ALLOCATION TO
PHYSICALLY THE FUNDING FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF ACTIVE A VERY
GOOD PLANNING WILL GO A LONG
WAY TOWARD GETTING LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CONTRACTING TO
REQUIRING AT THIS LANDMARK
CLIMATE BILL AHEAD OF THE
JANUARY FIRST IMPLEMENTATION
DEADLINE AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND
ONGOING EDUCATION TO SUPPORTING.
WEIGHT REDUCTION AND CLIMATE
ACTION. NUMBER THIRTY SIX.
THANK YOU MARTY- MOTO C. CAN'T
CALIFORNIA DISABILITY COMMUNITY
ACTION NETWORK ALSO A MEMBER OF
THE DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES TASK
FORCE MEMBER OF THE MASTER PLAN
FREAKING SUBCOMMITTEES JUST
WANT TO EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR
THE HUMAN SERVICES HEALTH AND
ALSO THE HOUSING BUT YOUR
TRAILER BILLS IN AGREE WITH THE
CHAIR THAT- THERE ARE MANY MANY
TRANSFORMING INITIATIVES IN THE
STATE BUDGET INCLUDING A RECORD
NUMBER OF INITIATIVES THAT ARE
TRANSFORMING THAT IMPACT PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES.
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS OLDER
CALIFORNIANS IN LOWER INCOME
CALIFORNIANS MANY OF THOSE ARE
LINKED- TO PERSON CENTRED
OUTCOMES THAT WE THINK WILL
ADDRESS THE ISSUES OF EQUITY
AND I MET NEED ESPECIALLY.
THOSE INITIATIVES IN THE ATV A
SPENDING PLAN WE APPLAUD. YOU.
NUMBER. SEVENTY FIVE. GOOD
EVENING BECAUSE WHEN THE WATER
CENTER AND ALL COMING OUT OF
THE WATER FOUNDATION AND CLEAN
WATER ACTION CALLING FOR
BUDGETARY WOULD BUILD A B. AT
THE ONE FIFTY FIVE AND WANT
THEM TO BE. TOGETHER WE SUPPORT
THE EXTENSION OF THE WATER SHUT
OFF MORATORIUM WHICH WILL
MAINTAIN CRITICAL WATER ACCESS
FOR RELIEF FUND IN THE WATER
AND WASTEWATER. REPAIR PROGRAM
ARE DISPERSED. WE ASKED FOR
LONGER EXTENSION ATTITUDE
MATCHED THE FUNDING DEADLINE
AND WE'LL WATCH THE PROGRAM AND
REPORT BACK- FIND HOW THAT
PLAYS OUT- WHICH I DON'T. WE
HAVE THE SUPPORT THE HUNDRED
EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS AND
YOU'RE READY FOR BATTLE GRONER
MANAGER ACTIVE LIMITATION. AND
THE MONEY PROVIDED FORTY FIVE-
INCREASING WATER- WE WANTED TO
TAKE BE DETERRED IN OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND STAFF AS
WELL DEMONSTRATION FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP BRINGING AMERICAN
WATER- THANK YOU. NUMBER.
SEVENTY SEVEN. GOOD EVENING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS MADE OF GREEN PARK I
REPRESENT AN ORGANIZATION
CALLED EQUITY TRADE WE HAVE A
EQUITY TRADE CERTIFICATION
MARKET- TO HELP IDENTIFY THE
PRODUCT IN THE MARKET PLACE-
FOR CANADA AN OPEN BEYOND. ON
THAT IT'S A PART OF AN EQUITY
PROGRAM I'M ACTUALLY CALLING
BECAUSE I AM A MEMBER ALSO THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS EQUITY
ALLIANCE AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL FOR- THE WORK ON IT-
ABIA THE ONE SIXTY SIX IN A
CREATING AN ACT WE DEFINITION
FOR THAT WE CAN. BE SURE THAT-
FIFTY FIVE NINETY FIVE WITH
REALIZED FIFTY WAIVERS-
ALTHOUGH THERE IS A LITTLE BIT
OF CONCERN AROUND THE
DEFINITION IN REGARDS TO
DECOUPLING LOW INCOME STATUS.
FROM A- FROM THE LOW INCOME
NEIGHBORHOODS- JUST BECAUSE
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
GENTRIFICATION AND A LOT OF OUR
CITIES SO THOSE WHO LIVE IN LOW
INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS NOT. NOT
OUR PART ALWAYS LOW INCOME AND-
SO SOMETIMES THEY GET THE
BENEFIT PERSON WHO IS ACTUALLY-
DESERVING OF THE BENEFIT-
BECAUSE THEY WERE PUSHED. OUT
OF THE NEIGHBORHOOD- ALL A
LITTLE BIT CONCERNED AROUND.
ONLY THE FIFTY- JUST BECAUSE
WITH THEIR FRANCISCO WE HAVE A
DEFINITION RIDE FOR YOU 9% AND
THE DECISION MAKING P. O. SO
KIND OF CONCERN AROUND WHETHER
OR NOT I. DON'T THINK THAT THE
FISCAL BE ABLE TO MEET THAT-
THAT DEFINITION I HAD WRITTEN
BUT VERY VERY GRATEFUL THAT
THERE IS A DEFINITION THE
MOVING FORWARD AND THAT WE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY. TO CONTINUE
WORKING THERE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NUMBER. SIXTY TWO. GOOD
EVENING- MY NAME IS ASHLEY
NICOLETTE FEAR PROVIDING
COMMENTS ON BEHALF OF THE SHIP
COUNSELING CENTER COMPLETED.
WHAT IT IS I THINK A GOOD FIRST
STEP IN CALLING FOR IN DEPTH
ANALYSIS AT THE TRUE COSTS AND
BENEFITS ASSOCIATED WITH THEIR
DOCTORS I WANT TO URGE
EVERYTHING SHE CONDUCTED BY
SOMEONE WHO DOES NOT HAVE HIGH
STANDARDS STREET. ORGANIZATIONS
AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS WITH A
PLEASANT STRONGLY OPPOSE ANY
ADDITIONAL TAXPAYER RATEPAYER
FUNDING FOR DAYS I GESTURES
INCLUDING THE PROPOSED. FORTY
EIGHT MILLION GENERAL FUNDS FOR
LIFE ON THIS INDUCTION FOR
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TO TWENTY THREE JOINING THE
RIGHT RESOURCE PACKAGE
SPREADSHEET THAT HAS. BEEN
CIRCULATING WE SUPPORT THE
EXPANSION OF THE WATER SHUT OFF
MORATORIUM HOWEVER THE ACTIVITY
AND IT'S REALLY SIMPLE GENTLE
JANUARY THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO THE COURT FOUND THAT
THE DATE IN THE WATER EVERY
WEEK PROGRAM. WE ALSO SUPPORT
THE HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION.
FIFTY ONE PUBLICATION. BUT
LANGUAGE FROM THE GOVERNOR
MAYBE MONTHLY AT IT BECAUSE A
VERY. RIGHT FOR DRINKING WATER.
AND IF THEY BUT BAD FOR THE-
THAT BENEFITS. FOR BENEFIT
UNITY. LAST FOUR SEVEN OF THE-
TO CENTER. BUT WE ARE TOO SAFE
AND THAT'S MUCH MORE THAN A
HUNDRED MILLION ALLOCATED. OVER
THE NEXT FEW YEARS OF THE.
PROGRAM THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NUMBER. SEVENTY NINE. REMEMBER
TO COLONIAL WE HAVE W. URBAN
PARTNERSHIP IN THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS EQUITY ALLIANCE ON AB
ONE SIXTY SIX WE ARE VERY
PLEASED TO SEE PROGRESS TOWARD
ESTABLISHING SOCIAL EQUITY
DEFINITION CAMERAS THREE NIGHTS
LONG OVERDUE THAT INCLUDES KEY
FACTORS THAT ARE DRESSING UP
PAST AND EQUITIES HOWEVER WE
FIND UNACCEPTABLE THAT THE
COUPLING OF LOW INCOME STATUS
THE FACT REMEBER IT'S MOST
DISPROPORTIONATELY HARMED AND
AFFECTED BY THE WAR ON DRUGS.
THERE'S A QUALITATIVE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN AN APPLICANT
WHO WAS LOW INCOME BUT NONE THE
LESS EMPLOYED WITH AN ABILITY
TO ACCESS CAPITAL AND THOSE WHO
ARE QUALIFIED DRUG WAR
SURVIVORS WORKING MY RESERVE
EXPERIENCE INCARCERATION FOR
CANNABIS OFFENSES DEEP
GENERATIONAL TRAUMA POVERTY
DIFFICULTY IN SECURING
SUBSEQUENT APPOINTMENTS AND
OFTEN CANNOT INDEPENDENTLY
SECURE ACCESS TO CAPITAL
BECAUSE DIVISION FIELD TO A
KNOWLEDGE THIS. WEEK THE
IMBALANCE BETWEEN THE TWO IN
PART BY CLINGING TO THE CONCEPT
OF REFERRALS WHEN THIS. REALLY
GOT ME A FEE WAIVER PROGRAM
ONLY. THANK YOU AND AGAIN WE
ALL THE HARD WORK PUT IN THIS
PRICE. THANK YOU. NUMBER. SIXTY
THREE. BECAUSE OF THAT THE-
THERE. SHARE MEMBERS ROBERT
HARRIS ON BEING OUT THERE YEAH
YOU CALIFORNIA COMMENTING ON.
EIGHTY ONE SIXTY SIX AND I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ADDRESSING THE ISSUE YEAH. D.
EQUITY YEAH HELLO THIS MAY NOT
BE PERFECT IT'S A GREAT FIRST
STEP. THANK YOU MUCH BYE. SURE
AT THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE IN OUR QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU SO MUCH-
MEMBERS WILL COME BACK WE HEARD
FROM OUR CALLERS AND- I FOUND
IT- I WAS PLEASED THAT- SO MANY
OF THE PUBLIC WHO CALLED IN.
WERE BRINGING UP THE ITEMS THAT
THEY REALLY- FELT GOOD ABOUT IN
THIS AND NOT ONLY IN THE PAST
BUDGET BUT IN THE ACTIONS WERE
TAKING TODAY. SO THERE'S LOTS
TO CELEBRATE. AND VERY GLAD
THAT WE HAD COLORS YOU
REFERENCED- THINGS LIKE OUR-
THE FINDINGS THAT WE ARE GOING
TO PROVIDE FOR OUR RECYCLING
PROGRAM SO THAT'S THE CIRCULAR
ECONOMY. ITEMS AND- A NUMBER OF
OTHER ITEMS THAT- WE OF COURSE
HADN'T YET DISCUSSED- ALL RIGHT
SO. LET ME SEE ANY LAST
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS BEFORE WE
START TAKING- MOTIONS ON BILLS
SENATOR DOLE YOU EVER MIKE UP
WAS THAT NO OKAY SO. LET'S- OUR
FIRST HELLO IS AB ONE SEVENTY
IT IS THE BUDGET ACT IT'S THE-
IT SHOULD THE MEMBER TO THE
BUDGET ACT SENATOR WHITE COUNTY.
ED HAS MOVED IT. SEEING NO
DISCRETION- SENATOR I MEAN HI
MR STEP IN SHOWER YOU CALL THE
ROLL. AB ONE SEVENTY THE MOTION
IS TO PASS SENATORS SKINNER HI.
THERE I. WILL SEND. ONE
SEVENTY. THIS IS THE- BUDGET
ACTIVE TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WE'RE
DOING THE VOTE. NIELSEN NO.
CABRERA CAIRO I CORTESE CORTESE
HI DOLLY DOLLY NO THE RAZA HI
TORONTO HI ADNAN. ADMIN HIGH
GROWTH. CAMARGO. COM LONGER HI
LAYERED. BLAIR TODD MAGUIRE
CHOIR HI MELINDA'S. MAN.MAN HI
NEWMAN. WOMEN HI THE TROUBLE.
PENN. PENN HI STERN I CALLOUSLY
BREAK OWSKI HI. RUSSIAN GERMAN.
PRICE TWELVE KNOWS. TO AB ONE
SEVENTY PASSES OUR EYES FIVE
TWELVE KNOWS TO CENTER GROVE
DID YOU HAVE A COMMENT OR
QUESTION YOU WANTED TO RAISE I
DIDN'T MADAM CHAIR WITHOUT
OBJECTION IS IT POSSIBLE AND I
DON'T KNOW IF IT IS BUT IF IS
IT POSSIBLE CAN WE KEEP TAKE UP
EIGHTY ONE SIXTY THREE AN SP.
ONE SIXTY THREE ONE SIXTY FIVE
ONE SIXTY SIX- SKEWS ME. ONE
SIXTY THREE ONE SIXTY FIVE ONE
SIXTY SEVEN ONE SIXTY EIGHT AND
ONE SIXTY NINE AND ONE SEVENTY
ONE. ALL IN ONE MOTION IS THAT
POSSIBLE. WITHOUT OBJECTION I
DON'T I HAVEN'T TALKED TO MY
COLLEAGUES SO I DON'T I'M JUST
ASK THOUGH- LET ME SEE IF YOUR
COLLEAGUES WOULD HAVE REPEAT
THE NUMBERS AGAIN IT'S AT THE
LOWER DARLING HAS EXISTED THREE
AND UP HE MAY HAVE AN
OBJECTION. SIXTY THREE. ONE
SEVEN R. I. OUR- OUR- NO- THANK
YOU FOR ANY WEIRD ONE OF WHICH
ONE POINT. THANK YOU FOR WE
COULD TAKE COULD WE TAKE THE
ROLE ON ONE AND THEN SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLE FOR THOSE OKAY LET US
TAKE THE RULE. ON LET ME DO A
B. ONE FIFTY FIVE WHICH WAS NOT
ONE OF THE ONES YOU MENTIONED
BUT LET US DO THAT AND THEN I
BELIEVE. YOU DIDIT WAS YOUR
FIRST BILL THAT YOU REFERENCED
WAS ONE SIX THREE. AVIAN SP ONE
SIXTY THREE OKAY SO LET US DO
THE ROLL CALLS ON EIGHTY ONE
FIVE FIVE IN AB ONE SIX TWO AND
THEN WE WILL. DO A ROLL CALL
ONE ONE SIX THREE. AND IF
THERE'S NO OBJECTION WE CAN
SUBSTITUTE THAT ROLL CALL FOR
THE VOTE FOR THE NEXT. ITEMS
RIGHT BUT LET'S FIRST PROCEED
WITH. LET'S GO WITH A B. ONE
FIFTY FIVE. WHICH IS THE
RESOURCES SENATOR RECOUNTS HE'S
MOVED. MR STOP AND SHOP PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. HI MISTER SEVEN
JOURNEY TO MIKE. A BABY ONE
FIFTY FIVE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS SENATORS SKINNER HI
SKINNER HI NIELSEN. NIELSEN I.
CABRERO COPYRIGHT HI CORTESE
CORTESE HI DOLLY. DOLLY NO
TORONTO. DORADO HI ADNAN. HEY
MAN HIGH GROWTH. GROVE NO COM
LARGER. COM LAGER HI LEHRER.
LEHRER HI MCGUIRE ENQUIRE HI
MELINDA. MAN. MAN I. NEWMAN NO
MAN HI THE TROUBLE. DURABLE NO.
PEN PEN HI EARNED BUY KOWSKI BY
KATHY HI. NELSON HI TO KNOW.
FOR EIGHT EIGHTY ONE FIFTY FIVE
PASSES TWELVE. ADVICE FOR KNOWS.
OKAY NOW ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON
AB ONE SIXTY TWO THE COMMUNITY
ECONOMIC RESILIENCE FIND WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR DRAWS
SO- CAN WE HAVE A ROLL CALL.
EIGHTY ONE SIXTY TWO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS SENATORS SKINNER BY
SKINNER HI. NIELSEN ALL RIGHT
NIELSEN HI COPYRIGHT. ZERO HI
CORTESE WITH THE HIGH DOLLY.
DAWALY NOTE TO RAZA. THE
ROSWELL HI EGGMAN EGGMAN HIGH
GROWTH. GROVE NO COM LOCKER.
CAMARGO HI GLARED. LEHRER I
MAGUIRE BLEIER I'M MELINDA
MELINDA IS NO MAN. MAN HI NIMIN.
NEWMAN HI THE TROUBLE. SHOW
BOAT NOW PAM. CAN I STERN WHAT
COUNTY HI BY CASCADE HI.
NIELSEN HI TO NARROW. RATE THAT
AB ONE SIXTY TWO PASSES. TWELVE
TO FIVE. TWELVE HOURS FIVE
NOTICE. ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO NOW
TO AB ONE SIXTY THREE ON STATE
GOVERNMENT. MOTION BY SENATOR
CORTESE ROLL CALL PLEASE MR
STOP AND SHOP. AB ONE SIXTY
THREE THE MOTION TO PASS
SENATORS SKINNER HI SKINNER HI
NILSSON NILSSON HI COPYRIGHT.
ZERO HI CORTESE RETIRES HE I.
DALI. DOLLY I'D RATHER. RATHER
HI ADNAN. DEGREE IN HIGH GROWTH.
GROWTH HI COM LONGER. COM
LOGGER HI LAYERED. LAYERED HI
WIRE WIRE I MELINDA'S.
MELINDA'S HIDE ME IN. MAN I
KNOW MAN. NEWMAN HI THE TROUBLE
THE TROUBLE I CAN. THEN I TURN
WHAT COUNTY BREAK OUT SKI HI-
AB ONE SIXTY THREE PASSES
SEVENTEEN ICE. NOW. FOR THIS-
WHAT ARE THE BILLS YOU WOULD
LIKE TO. BUT S. TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLE FOR A. B. WHEN SIXTY
THREE SP ONE SIXTY THREE WITH
SUCH A ROLE WITH. ONE SIXTY
FIVE. ONE SIXTY EIGHT ONE
SIXTEEN NINE AND ONE SEVENTY
ONE. OR IF THERE'S NO OBJECTION
WE WILL USE THAT. WE WILL
SUBSTITUTE THE VOTE OF ONE
SIXTY THREE FOUR AB ONE SIX
FIVE AB. ONE SIX EIGHT EIGHTY
ONE SIX NINE AND AB ONE SEVEN
ONE. SEEING NO OBJECTION THAN
THOSE BILLS PASSED ON A VOTE OF.
SEVENTEEN ZERO. ALL RIGHT NOW
LET'S DO- AB ONE SIXTY SIX THE-
DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS CONTROL
MOTION. A SENATOR- COPYRIGHT.
MR STOP AND SHOP PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. AB ONE SIXTY SIX THE
MOTION TO PASS SENATORS SKINNER
HI SKINNER HI NIELSEN NO NO SIN
NO COPYRIGHT. CABRERO HI
CORTESE ALL RIGHT TO THE HI
DOLLY. DALI NO-DIROCCO DRAGO
HI ADNAN. HEY MAN I GROW. GROSS
NO COM LARGER. CAMARGO HIGH
LAYERED. LEHRER HI MCGUIRE.
CHOIR I BELIEVE THIS WHEN IS IT
MELINDA'S NO MAN. MAN HI NEWMAN.
NO MAN HI THE TROUBLE. YOUR
VOTE NO PENN N. I. STERN WHAT
KOWSKI BY KATHY HI RIGHT THAT
BILL AB ONE SIX SIX PASSES
WHICH BY. TWELVE TO FIVE. ALL
RIGHT MOTION ON AB ONE SIXTY
SEVEN. ON EDUCATION. ONE SIXTY
SEVEN WAS NOT A SUBSTITUTE
MOTION. APOLOGIES WHY MISTER AT
THAT'S- MOVED BY SENATOR
CAFIERO. I'M SORRY SENATOR
GROWTH IF YOU WANT TO SHARE IT
WITH PERMISSION WITHOUT
OBJECTION CANNOT SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLE FOR AB ONE SIXTY SIX AND
SP ONE SIXTY SIX. FOR ONE
SEVENTY TWO ONE SEVENTY FIVE
AND WE DO THAT AFTER WE WON IT
WE ARE JEALOUS AND HE WANTS THE
SEVEN RIGHT NOW. K. BUT STILL
WITH THAT SO LET'S DEAL WITH
ONE SIXTY SEVEN. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR CAFIERO- MR
STEPHENS ARE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. AB ONE SIXTY SEVEN THE
MOTIONS TO PASS SENATOR SKINNER
HI SKINNER HI NIELSEN. YES AND
I CAIRO CAIRO I WHERE DOES THE-
WHAT IS THE I. DALI. THE RISE
OF. THE RUSSELL HI ADNAN. WHEN
I GROW GROVE HI COME LONGER.
COM LONGER BY LAYER. LEHRER I'M
A WIRE MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S
MELINDA'S HI MAN. MAN I KNOW
MAN. NEWMAN HI- TROUBLE. OKAY A
TERRIBLE GUY. PEN PEN HI STERN
BY CASKEY KATHY HI. THE COUNTER
I HAVE IS- SIXTEEN. SIXTEEN
ZERO ZERO A. B. ONE SIXTY SEVEN
PASSES SIXTEEN ZERO. ALL RIGHT
NOW EIGHTY ONE SEVENTY TWO
HUMAN SERVICES. SENATOR GROW.
HEY THERE'S A CONFLICT IN VOTES
WE- SO I HAVE TO WITHDRAW THAT
MOTION OKAY MA'AM MAYBE ONE
SEVENTY TWO HUMAN SERVICES DO
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THAT AS
SENATOR EKMAN MOVES LET'S DO A
ROLL CALL. YOU WANT AP ONE
SEVENTY TWO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS SENATORS SKINNER BY
SKINNER I NELSON. NIELSEN HI
COPYRIGHT COPYRIGHT HI CORTESE
DAISY HI DOLLY. DOLLY NO THE
RAZA. TORONTO HI ADNAN. HIGH
GROWTH. GROVE NOT VOTING COM
LARGER COM LARGER HI LAYERED.
LEHRER HI WIRE. MCGUIRE HI
LINDA. MAN MAN I KNOW MAN.
NEWMAN I THE TROUBLE. TALK
ABOUT A JOB I. PEN PEN HI STERN
BY CAL SKI BY CASKEY HI- THAT
AB ONE SEVENTY TWO IS THAT THE
VOTERS. FOURTEEN ONE. OKAY
BILLS ACT RIGHT EIGHTY ONE
SEVENTY THREE PUBLIC SAFETY THE
MOTION BY SENATOR DRAWS SO- MR
STOP AND SHOP PLEASE READ THE
ROLE. AB ONE SEVEN THREE THE
MOTIONS TO PAST SENATORS
SKINNER HI SKINNER HI NELSON.
NIELSEN NO COPYRIGHT. HI
CORTESE WHAT IS THE HI DOLLY
DOLLY NO TORONTO. TORONTO HI
ADNAN TAKING IN HIGH GROWTH
GROVE NO COMMAGER COMMA- I
LAYERED. LEHRER HI MCGUIRE.
WIRE HI MELINDA MELINDA'S NO
MAN MAN HI NEWMAN. NEWMAN HI
THE TROUBLE. THE TROUBLE A
TROUBLED NOW. TEN PAN HI STERN
WHAT COUNTY BY COUNTY HI BABY
ONE SEVENTY THREE IS OUT WITH A
TWELVE YES FIVE NO VOTE.
CORRECT WE'LL NOW GO TO EIGHTY
ONE SEVENTY FOUR WE HAVE A
MOTION- SENATOR WHITE HOUSE MR
STOPPING SHORT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. EIGHTY ONE SEVENTY FOR
THE MOTION IS TO PASS. SENATOR
SKINNER SKINNER HI NELSON.
NELSON HI COPYRIGHT. HI CORTESE
ALL RIGHT THE HI DARLING. THE
RADO THE RADO I MEAN HEY MAN I
GROW. COME LONGER. CAMARGO HI
THERE. LEHRER HI WIRE. ENQUIRE
HI MELINDA'S MELINDA'S HI MAN.
MAN I NEWMAN NEWMAN HI- TROUBLE
THE ABOVE HI AND THEN I TURNED
LIKE KATHY KATHY HI READY BE
ONE SEVENTY FOUR IS OUT.
FIFTEEN ZERO. OKAY WE'RE GOING
TO BE ONE SEVENTY FIVE HOUSING.
THE MOTION BY SENATOR CAFIERO-
MR SECOND JOB PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. NOW WITH. ONE SEVENTY
FIVE I DON'T THINK WE HAD THAT
ONE IN OUR SUBSTITUTE NO NO NO
OKAY. CALL THE ROLL. FIFTY ONE
SEVENTY FIVE THE MOST OF THE
PAST SENATORS SCANNER HI
SKINNER HI NIELSEN. NIELSEN I
COVER YOUR- HI CORTESE HEY THE
ONCOLOGY. THE RADO THE RADO HI
ADNAN HEY CAN I GROW. COMMA-
CALMER HI THERE LEHRER HI BUYER.
MMHM MCGUIRE- CHOIR HI
MELINDA'S. MAN MAN HEINEMAN.
NEWMAN I HAVE TROUBLE. PENN M.
I. STERN WHITE COUNTY BY KATHY
HI. THIRTY ONE SEVENTY FIVE OUT
THE VOTE IS THIRTEEN ZERO. OKAY
AB ONE SEVENTY SIX WE'VE GOT A
MOTION BY SENATOR COM LAGER MR
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT MR STOP
AND SHOP PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
EIGHTY ONE SEVENTY SIX EMOTIONS
DO PAST SENATORS SCANNER. BY
SKINNER I NELSON NELSON I HAVE
YOUR OWN CAREER HI FIDELITY ALL
RIGHT THE HI DOLLY. TORONTO HI
BROTHER I AM IN SUCH ECONOMIC
GROWTH. COM AUGER COMMA- I
LAYERED. LEHRER HI I'M A WIRE
WIRE HI MELINDA'S. MAN HI MAN
HI NEWMAN. NEWMAN I THE TROUBLE.
IN. CAN I TURN MY CASKET HI BY
KATHY HI LAURIE EIGHTY ONE
SEVENTY SIX IS OUT. THIRTEEN
ZERO. RIGHT FINAL BILL AB ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN ON THE COURT'S
MOTION BY SENATOR DRAWS- MR
STOP AND SHOP PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL EIGHTY ONE SEVENTY SEVEN
THE MOTIONS DO PAST SENATORS
SKINNER. SKINNER HI NIELSEN
WELL YES AND NO CORRECT
COPYRIGHT FEBRERO HI CORTESE
ALL RIGHT THIRTY HI DOLLY. DALI
KNOWN TO RAZA. TORONTO I'M
RATHER HI EIGHT MINS HI. ADNAN
OUR GROWTH. GROSS NO. COM
LONGER KAMBAR- I LAYER ON LAYER
TIME ACQUIRED. ENQUIRE HI
MELINDA MELINDA'S NO MAN. HI
MAN I. NEWMAN NEWMAN I- TURBO.
PAN HI CAN I TURN. BY CAL SKI
BY MY COUNT HI- EIGHTY ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN PASSES TWELVE YES
FOR NO. THE FACT THAT CONCLUDES
OUR BUSINESS THANK YOU MEMBERS
THANK YOU AGAIN STAFF FOR YOUR
HARD WORK ON THIS- FINAL BUDGET
COMMITTEE HEARING THE STAFF OF
VIOLENCE- AS YOU ALL KNOW.
HOURS AND HOURS OF GOOD WORK ON
IT THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND- I THINK ALL OF
THOSE WHO WERE INVOLVED IN THE
VARIOUS NEGOTIATIONS ON THE
ADMINISTRATION OUR COLLEAGUES
IN THE OTHER HOUSE AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO TAKING UP THESE
BILLS. AS SOON AS THE SEVENTY
TWO HOUR LAW ALLOWS AND WITH
THAT. WE WILL CONCLUDE THE
SENATE BUDGET- CAN HELP ONE
SECOND- SENATOR NIELSEN GO
AHEAD. SENATOR NELSON GO AHEAD.
MADAM PRESIDENT LATER ON THE
SENATE TO COMMAND THE
REPUBLICAN FISCAL STAFF THEY
LIKE THE DEMOCRATIC FISCAL
STAFF LABOR LONG LONG HOURS. DR
NIGHT ALL DAY FOR US TO HELP US
DO OUR JOBS I'D LIKE. THAT FIND
P. ABSOLUTELY APPROPRIATE WHEN
I SAID STAFF I WAS NOT
EXCLUDING ANY BUT VERY GOOD TO.
TO POINT THAT OUT AND OF COURSE
OUR FLOOR STAFF ALWAYS ON- INTO
STORE NEARLY DILIGENT MAKING
SURE THAT WE- FOLLOW THE
APPROPRIATE ROLE SO THAT OUR
VOTES COUNT AND THEN KEEPING US
SAFE SO WITH THAT WITHOUT ANY
OTHER COMMENTS. THE US SENATE
BUDGET COMMITTEE BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEWWILL
CONCLUDE A JERK.